there's no time o clock okay and we are
back this is gonna be a good show
tonight this is gonna be a cannibal show
and it's gonna have to do with cannibals
in the Old West it's almost kind of like
in honor of crustle
and you know bone tomahawk what's on the
list yeah yeah we are gonna do some one
a long time ago requested that we do
Alfred or Alfred Packer he's known as
both things also known as the Colorado
cannibal and I figured since we were
doing that I guess we would talk about
the even more famous tale of frontier
cannibalism a good ol Donner Party yeah
ain't no party like a Donner Party which
one we gonna do first no one wants to go
to a Donner Party well we're probably
gonna talk about Alfred powder first and
then we'll do the part and then we'll do
the yeah this is not a party anyone who
wants to get invited to it's a horrible
horrible horrible story The Alfred
Packer one is kind of different in in
the sense that it's more ambiguous we
don't really know if he ended up eating
people because he had to or just because
he just kind of did it you know what I
mean
I know quite a bit about the Donner
Party I read a book about it a long time
ago when I was a kid I don't know how
accurate was the scene a few programs on
it but the the Alfred guy I've heard of
him but I don't know all the details
he's the guy that you know um the the
guys that did South Park and they did
that musical that was called cannibal
the musical that's uh that's about
Alfred okay like it's based on his story
I think we talked about another cannibal
like that Scottish cannibal clan the
Sawney bean and his family that kind of
that The Hills Have Eyes was based on
but uh yeah this guy is actually quite
famous in Colorado and the best thing
about this or weirdest I mean you know
if you're into like dark humor and stuff
is that there's a whole [ __ ] ton of
restaurants and cafeterias in Suffolk
Colorado the church that stuff but also
kind of funny so when I remember he was
kind of like kind of like a mountain man
slash gunfighter and you know prospector
prospector yeah but he also carries
Olson was heavily armed and I think he
shot people too if it's the same one I'm
thinking of they're not really sure like
I said no one is entirely sure what
happened out there on the expedition
that they went on because he was the
only one who returned yeah and he gave
at least three different yeah yeah
stories over the years like of what
actually happened and I kind of suspect
you know even though he's almost kind of
like I think in Colorado you know among
certain segments of the population I
guess he's kind of like a folk hero or
like kind of a local legend type of
thing even though I'm pretty sure he
just like straight-up murdering people
yeah probably
it was guys that were with him I think
yeah yeah yeah yeah so we'll get into
that first and then after that we'll
talk about the Donner Party earlier
today I was listening to last podcast on
the left at a two-part series on the
Donner Party that was hilarious but also
horrifying and they they recommended a
book I can't remember who wrote it but
it was called oh [ __ ] um do to do to do
something belt in different stars or
something like that
but it sounded like a really kick-ass
book and all three of them had read it
and they kept like recommending it over
and over because it was like really good
but it was all about the Donner Party
and it went like into exhaustive detail
about like all this [ __ ] that happen and
like all the families and everything so
we'll get into that a little bit as well
but before we do that let's do a couple
of brief shoutouts we have one new
patron this week named the mystery gamer
intriguing okay so thank you very much
for
being a patron he's a gamer yeah he's
mysterious it's mystery or she
mysterious I don't know playing some
kind of mysterious ass game oh yeah so
you know we always appreciate you guys
and your patronage
like I said we're eventually gonna do
the whole YouTube membership thing as
well if you don't want to do patreon and
if you'd like to contribute to the show
you'll be able to go through the YouTube
membership thing but like I said that
might be a while for it uh goes up also
I think I mentioned these on probably on
some of our sidetrack shows but I know
that we don't you know a lot of people
not as many people listen to those as
listen to these so I wanted to give
another shout out to Eric for sending me
the book about the atelier sand whatever
the house and also I wanted to thank
Marcus again for sending us those four
movies yeah we already watched one of
them chef Marcus chef chef Marcus yeah
we watched one of them art it's pretty
good it was the was gone it was one
about incarnate incarnate the possession
one yeah can't imagine like there's a
plumb house movie yeah imagine Chuck
Norris doing exorcisms it's kinda like
Chuck Norris has a pie
it's demon ass-kicking demon p.m.
telling you and I can't remember god
damn it I can't remember the name of it
because remember I told you like my
ex-husband was like a huge Chuck Norris
fan so i against my better judgment I
saw pretty much every movie that Chuck
Norris ever made there was one where it
was like a religious one where he was
like fighting the devil or went to hell
or something like that it's been like
many years since I've seen it but it had
that type of must have been went Chuck
went all religious yeah well he's been
religious for a really long time yeah
even back in like the back in the
Octagon I'm not sure about that I don't
know if he was and you know he just
wasn't like loud and proud about it but
it did seem like later on you know as
his stuff went more into like
direct-to-dvd type newest territory I
liked I liked action flicks but I never
got into
Norris he just always seemed bland to me
he is very bland just kind of bland yeah
I don't really get like I can see
watching him for like you know the
fighting because he is actually a good
fighter unlike some other people we
could name but we did a show about a few
weeks years ago but uh but yeah so I can
see it like getting into it because of
that but he's just like he's very blank
he can't like a moat it's like he's not
a character really no yeah and it's like
yeah he doesn't really have like a lot
of charisma or like a lot of personality
really the only movie of his that I
really liked was that one that was kind
of more like a horror movie the Octagon
was pretty good but when and I came over
the name of that either cuz goddamnit
I'm not even drunk or anything at least
Segal you know what you're getting and
the dude the dude in and he had some
good movies in the beginning he was
entertaining and and he's an amazing man
he's an amazing man he would be the
first very interesting character be the
first now you know we've sampled some of
his like we said before that shows we've
sampled some of his weren't his newer
shows that [ __ ] boring he's not
hardly hit him and he's just kind of
fallen a man yeah that's like the
textbook definition of phony is he's
like I'll be in your movie but I'm just
gonna sit here and mumble through his
movie nine minutes
it's him in his own movie and then I'm
gonna go sit in my no it's you yes
that's the amazing thing he's phoning it
in on his own movie that is very strange
it's I can't really think of anybody
else that does that type of thing yeah
it's like I you know reducing them yeah
it's like it's almost kind of like oh
it's a passion project like this is the
movie I want to make it I'm gonna fund
it and pretty soon you like that but it
would be bothered to like after a walk
or anything he had a stunt double walk
down the stairs for it yeah we saw that
[ __ ] body double well like I said you
want anybody knowing that a long time
ago because I saw like a clip from a
movie that was from like the 90s like a
late 90s er no it was from 2006 um you
know which was a long time ago doesn't
seem like it but where they had yet like
he had a stunt double that walked out
yeah like walked across the
room and out on the balcony and like I
said the stunt double just turned toward
the camp they didn't care that every
time you can see his face and it wasn't
him every time he has a line and they
cut to him he's behind some yeah
remember that his sandbags they're not
amazing he's like he's down behind cover
you never actually see his body just his
head yeah he doesn't want anybody seeing
like that yeah when you do see his body
it's just flashes of it and then they
try to use a stunt double from the back
as much as they can to me it looks like
you know he's [ __ ] telling to do that
well yeah of course you know I had that
back injury and I don't wanna you know I
don't want anybody to see they haven't
recovered from my back he doesn't want
anybody to see this eternal that yeah
that lives underneath yeah he's he's
become a [ __ ] big ass terrible what
was what's funny about now I'm getting
on [ __ ] Segal alright but that's what
he did a whole show about warming up I'm
warming up
if Segal were to embrace that [ __ ] and
kind of do a Segal parody where he's
kind of parroting himself kind like they
did in the Expendables yeah it might be
a hit but like I said he can so but
that's why everybody that's where
everybody picks on them all the time
because it's easy serious she says you
got to have some but you know so is
Norris I think Chuck Norris took himself
very very seriously
oh definitely didn't like those Chuck
Norris [ __ ] G quotes there Chuck
Norris facts he tried to see that guy
yeah that's ridiculous I mean I remember
yeah later on he kind of like he was
like okay fine and he like went along
with the joke but yeah he tried to see
the guy that wrote that book and also he
used to go after I you know I don't know
who the hell would hire somebody like
this but you know how they have like
celebrity look-alikes it'll like show up
at your big parties or whatever it's
like but they don't build themselves as
being the real person it's just kind of
like a novelty like hey let's have yeah
these look like so apparently this one
guy who was making his living as a Chuck
Norris look-alike Chuck Norris inator
tried to see that guy's you take this
and I'm like okay moneybags it's like
here's this poor guy that's just hey I
look like Chuck Norris maybe I could
make a living like Chuck Norris
impersonator yeah and he's not saying
that he's actually Chuck Norris
right it says right there he's a Chuck
Norris impersonators yes like get him to
show up with parties and stuff and it's
funny and everybody has like a little
chuckle about it yeah but now we have
having a chuckle on Chuck yeah I should
like go back and just say yeah I totally
did that a person having a chuckle at
Chuck success but yeah so alright we are
we done talking about we're done we're
done about martial arts I just went down
a dam or just kind of like we get on
that topic and we get on food and as we
were watching martial arts movies
recently you know it's like in the one
about you know what was it [ __ ]
artists self-defense guys yeah it's a
movie that boobies [ __ ] fantastic
yeah reddit that's great I mean that's I
mean it's like good it's like a truce
it's like a true story yes wait count
Dante in the [ __ ] Black Dragon
Society they were bow like that yeah
well I figure well probably martial arts
aside we probably are gonna end up on
more food jokes be good since we're
talking about cannibals
just like we done the Jeffrey Dahmer
show which I didn't really mean for that
to happen I'm not worried about this is
not corporate entertainment this is not
corporate this is from where we are
independent you're independent
entertainers on YouTube oh it makes it
sound so important yeah it's better you
don't have to worry about [ __ ]
advertisers or corporate backing or
anything just long as [ __ ] YouTube
doesn't step on our dick yeah and I got
what dicks we have a Dickie ain't gonna
let you out of it
I have an honorary Navin honorary okay
starts just like this one I might be an
[ __ ] but I am funny
alright so should we talk about the the
people eating that's good before you
were your you're running the show man
you're in charge of this [ __ ] am i
you're in charge it doesn't feel like
it's not she's just this this your
imagination
[ __ ] I'm just like in common okay go
ahead
alright so oh I should say to that if
you're interested in alfred packer which
is what is wikipedia page is called even
though most of the time he's called
Alfred and I'm just gonna call him
Alfred because who the [ __ ] is named
Alfred and I'm not saying that but
there's a Harold Schechter who was a
very famous true crime writer he's
written a book about seemingly every
true crime you could possibly think of
and he's on pretty much every big
documentary about serial killers and
stuff he wrote a book about Alfred
Packer that was called maneater yeah so
uh that's that I've heard is very good
I've read like excerpts of it it's true
but I like all his books like he's a
really good writer the ones of his that
I've read so Alfred G Packer or Alfred
as I said um as I said there is some
controversy over what exactly happened
during this little expedition that he
went on because over the years he has
given several different accounts of what
happened and because there were no other
witnesses to come forward and go hey no
he's making that up or whatever no one
knows exactly what happened although you
know kind of looking into the forensic
evidence let's call it that I have my
suspicions about what probably happened
and I kind of think that he didn't need
to eat these dudes that he just kind of
did it
maybe had habits we all have habits yeah
he had this nasty habit of just like
killing people and eating them I just
don't know but I think that in a context
that was gonna be a gif of me going up
but that dancer Marvin some he picked up
before he went out on a range yeah you
know this is 1800s
I hope you going to realize how wild
[ __ ] New York was in the eighteen
well it seemed gangs in New York you
know but there were even the big cities
of the 1800s here in the United States
had [ __ ] horrendous ghettos filled
with [ __ ] people from Ireland to
Germany and Poland and they did weird
[ __ ] in there
weird [ __ ] what happened in there and it
wouldn't surprise me of cannibalism was
something that could happen ever down
that yeah that totally wouldn't shock me
there I must say no when surprised me at
all
I talked about very intense poverty yeah
and lots of criminal activity yeah no
law enforcement to speak up yeah not
like you could just call 9-1-1 yeah you
know I Sonny you know modern people take
[ __ ] so much [ __ ] from [ __ ] granted
you don't mean that you can just call a
cop and the cop shows up well [ __ ] even
nowadays yeah this you can call the
coppers just know they're not gonna like
ya go check out Detroit yeah yeah we'll
totally be there in a minute
yeah our place is right with the other
signs I don't know if they're still up
there but they're alike you know but
then there is no police service in this
area enter at your own risk and they
[ __ ] mean it yeah you could be like
the predator and grab them assault
assault rifle and put on some camo and
go around and just shoot people probably
for days as long as you did it wasn't a
lot of it and they don't think I don't
think they're gay I don't think they
care probably the cops wouldn't care the
locals would handle it
they'd come after it themselves if they
could yeah cuz you know if you were down
there burning down the whole [ __ ]
town you know Killa yes you're gonna get
a little mist well the cops will
eventually come yeah if you went out
there maybe kill them one every few days
it probably wouldn't they probably
wouldn't notice I like yeah if I
wouldn't notice any spike or anything
there's no police service that's what it
meant
yeah well a lot of cities were like that
in the eighteen hundreds there was just
and and another thing is that the
concept of a professional policeman yeah
that's kind of a new cop it's a fairly
modern college yeah yeah they didn't
have him they had kind of like local
police but they were more like a night
watchman or a security guard they might
have to call some common investigator if
they gave a [ __ ] and tried to do some
kind of an investigation but that was
only for an important person really well
in the thing about these particular
cases the case of Alfred Packer and the
Donner Party is that these didn't even
happen in cities these were like out in
the [ __ ] frontier
yeah impossible where there was like no
they weren't even States yet in
right of cases it was just like you know
just random like people Ragan trains
Native American tribes and that's about
it the closest thing to a policeman /
investigative body / may be security /
Authority would have been the Pinkertons
yeah which was a private corporation
that for a long time even the president
used as bodyguards and you know and like
Secret Service yeah they're famous yeah
for that reason Pinkertons were Dave go
and look for somebody and arrest him
they could do a rout a pretty good
investigation with the technology at the
time but there were only maybe a few
thousand of those though in the
Pinkerton company you know it was little
well you have to imagine do you this
Myatt yeah when this happened with like
the Alpha Packer case this happened in
the 1870s this was even before let's say
in England like Jack the Ripper where
it's like they didn't even have
fingerprinting they'd have anything like
that it's like you pretty much unless
you saw somebody like actually
committing murder in front of your face
they were probably not gonna catch you
yeah and then you know courts were iffy
back then and if you had a good lawyer
and a lot of money you could get wasted
witness testimony discounted yeah yeah
no it was luck whether or not you got
off or not luck and money well yeah
whether or not you got convicted or you
know yeah like to an even greater
extreme than nowadays yeah yeah you know
what I mean because obviously if you
have money now it is you probably a lot
of the gun fighters of the Wild West or
the Old West you know killed 20 30
people and never served a day a lot of
them or if they did serve just a little
bit because they would say well there
was self-defense
yeah you know they were he was you know
that guy came after him so of course he
shot him and that's not defense one of
the things that was one of the tales
that Packard's run as well self-defense
was just pretty much blanketed
everything yeah and you know I don't
doubt that dudes fought yeah they did a
lot and all of that was Russian I'm sure
it wasn't yeah and but there's another
thing too you know guys like you know
John Wesley Hardin and you know they
were fearsome
if you testified against him he'd get
out eventually probably because he was
well known and the Conte and the guys
maybe shooting were other gun fighters
so he'd get out in a couple years even
he was found guilty he they wouldn't
kill him for that he'd kill you if you
testified against him so probably best
just say no it was self-defense
I saw it happened dude came at him do
draw there do drew you know please don't
kill me like samurai days yeah man you
can't better they're all cooking
carrying weapons and if they didn't like
each other and they were they were kind
of like what was going on with Musashi
you know you'd get challenged a lot if
you had a badass reputation yeah well
yeah cuz everybody wants to be the guy
who killed John Wesley ours yeah yeah no
Hardin got out and became a lawyer later
yeah he was probably one of the best
ones I think well yeah he's kind of an
American legend yeah and there's the
kind of a story that he shot a guy for
snore and that's not really how it
happened though I was an accident
yeah shooting somebody for snoring too
odd it's like it sounds excessive but if
you had to sleep with the same person
all the time and they were just
constantly - I think eventually it would
be like water torture know what it was
but I'm just saying they were in this
hotel and it was right outside of
brothel and it was kind of a cheap hotel
and they were all in there trashed and
[ __ ] you know and hardened gets in
there and trying to get some sleep but
the dude in the room next to him his
[ __ ] snore him and he shot the wall
makes a guy up and then rolled back over
and fell asleep but he didn't nobody
actually hit he hit the guy they were
all drunk yeah - they were all drunk and
Evans in his defense he didn't run
because he didn't know he hit the guy
right he was just drunk a shot at the
wall trying to wake him up yeah I know
that they didn't have anything against
each other you know what I mean yeah you
don't partner and and that hole and it
was like on a Saturday night they were
all [ __ ] wasted I mean technically
it's true that he shot a guy for snoring
too loud it's just that he didn't really
intend to shoot him No
sorry didn't try to he wasn't trying to
kill him right so all right so the year
is 1873
here's Alfred Packer he's 31 years old
now him and a group of 20 other
prospectors are going on an expedition
from Bingham Canyon Utah into the San
Juan Mountains in Colorado looking for
gold and various other valuable minerals
now later on he said that he'd actually
been the guide or like the head of this
expedition but I don't believe that that
was the case he was probably just like
you know puffing his own ego up or
whatever so they go out on this they
start to go out on this expedition and
evidently they lost some of their food
on the way I don't know who's stolen or
like someone dropped it off a cliff I
don't know
but so they lost some of the food and
started getting really hungry so January
1874 they turned up at a ute camp
this was in northwestern Colorado now
they get there they're also alive and
[ __ ] like that but you know the the
chief or a I think is how you pronounce
his name he was like look you guys um
you know we'll give you some food and
we'll give you like so you can stay here
and stuff but he's like you really
should stay here until springtime
because if you set out you know going
where you were gonna go on your
expedition it's really really dangerous
like the mountain passes are very
dangerous and it's you like if you go
before like the thaw and everything then
you could be camping and just be buried
in snow and that is no fun for anyone
however five of the prospectors and
Alfred Packer decided they don't want to
hear that [ __ ] they're like no man we're
gonna have to go now because then we'll
get to the mines and get all the good
[ __ ] before anybody else gets there so
we want to go right now
even though it's an immensely stupid
idea so these six dudes they're like no
we're just gonna go and at which point
like chief orys probably liked out of my
hands [ __ ] it's like I tried to
tell you
so they leave on February 9th
now they apparently only took a 10 day
supply of food with them even though
there were six of them they thought that
the journey was only 40 miles however it
was actually 75 miles which apparently
they were not aware of
so other than Alfred Packer the other
five guys who went with him were named
Shannon Belle Israel Swan
James Humphrey Frank Miller and George
California noon who was only 18 years
old so they leave and those five guys
that's the last time anybody ever saw
hmm
more than two months go by people are
starting to wonder I mean I guess these
guys had families and friends and stuff
like that I'm like you know I wonder
whatever happened they went off on that
expedition we haven't heard hiding her
hair of them since they took off now
there are differing accounts of what
happened next that apparently it was
either that there was a party of
prospectors like a different party that
came through you know at this outpost in
the spring and we're asking about them
and then later Blake sent a search party
out however the more famous account of
the of what happened was that Alfred
Packer came wandering back out all alone
you know so this was a April 6th or
April 16th again sources differ there
also there was also evidence that he
might have been seen a week earlier in a
nearby town he turned up at the the Los
Pinos Indian agency in Colorado although
like I said some witnesses said that
they had seen him a week earlier in a
town called Sag watching I guess is how
you pronounce it sig watching now when
he turned up he had
ominously a whole bunch of wallets yeah
and he took like a whole bunch of money
out of there now he said that he hadn't
eaten in a day or two however when he
got there he had all this money but he
didn't like buy any food he just was
like oh I want some whiskey looking bad
already I'm telling you this yes this is
[ __ ] up
now his story initially was that oh well
we were only a few days into the
expedition and I hurt my leg and fell
behind the other ones so I don't have
any idea where they went
I thought that they would beat me back
here like I would get back here on my
own and they would be here ahead of me
because I thought they were they had
gone on ahead
that was his initial story so even from
the beginning people in this saloon that
he turned up at they're like that sounds
not entirely plausible like because no
one has heard from these five guys since
they took off a lot of times that's not
what the guy says it's how he says yeah
it probably there's a bunch of
voice-stress in him and just the way he
was talking they're like man he's lying
yeah like nobody seemed to buy it like
even from the beginning
yeah sketchy kind of way of [ __ ]
talking about it and they're like this
dude's [ __ ] hide something yeah
because they're like you know somebody
they're like if these dudes were still
wandering around somebody would have
heard from at least one of them and also
they thought it was very suspicious that
he had all these wallets and all this
money that everyone presumed probably
correctly that he had stolen from the
five guys yeah sounds like it
so then later on apparently an Indian
guide is walking along the trail that a
packer and the other guys had taken off
on and find some suspicious-looking
strips of meat yeah that turn out to be
human flesh now how did he have they
find out that it was human I'm not
really sure maybe it looked like maybe
it was like a nose I don't know they
really fun we kind of hanging somewhere
drove it I guess they were just kind of
like along the trail like on the you
know there was just like little scraps
there were like pieces or whatever okay
so so they were prepared you know
somewhat jerky I know I don't think it
was
trips of flesh I was thinking jerky it
might have been because they do
sometimes like have to jerky people if
you're gonna like yeah but it takes time
to make it well yeah and you have to
know how to do it this dude probably
doesn't know how to do it maybe not I
don't know I kind of feel like making
jerky was probably a pretty common skill
back then especially if you're gonna be
wandering into the wilderness for any
like the time well you got to have the
right conditions or it'll just [ __ ]
rot well yeah and the Flies will get on
it right yeah what it's probably better
just to sit there and smoke it and then
just wrap it there's a bunch of
different ways of doing stuff they used
to rap but you have to have spices but
you know yeah it doesn't matter I'm
tasting here thinking of a recipe on how
to [ __ ] do that's what see I knew
that was gonna happen because like as
soon as [ __ ] cannibalism because it
becomes a topic everyone's gonna start
talking about recipes I want to make all
these jerky makers now we can make jerky
right on a damn close car neck part car
lay it out there dude just [ __ ] turn
right into jerky probably would ya in
the Florida heat yeah just like a couple
times in the summer just for shits and
giggles I wanted to see if I could
actually cook an egg on the driveway
like not this driveway but like at my
grandmother's house it worked
hmm floor Niall so yeah so as I said you
know nobody bought his initial version
was like he was just got left behind
so nobody bought it so apparently there
was like a lot of pressure on him like
people kept bugging him to be like come
on man it's like we know that's not what
happened
you really need to like tell us what
really happened to these people because
it's not looking good so about a month
after he had returned he finally said
okay um yeah I I know what happened to
everybody and I will give you a
confession this was on May 8th of 1874
so he gave a confession and this was
like it was like signed over like to buy
some official whatever so this was his
so I guess this would be the second
version of the story because the first
version was that he
didn't know what happened to him like
they just like left him in heat they
were alive he left him this is the
second version of what he said happened
he said that pretty much as soon as they
started out on the expedition he said
the weather was really shitty and their
supplies of which they had not taken
enough because they thought the the
journey was about half of the length of
what it actually was that their supplies
ran out then they said that the lakes
were like frozen so they couldn't really
fish in there that there wasn't a lot of
game and they couldn't hunt and they
said they were at a spot where it's like
well we didn't it was too far to go back
but like we didn't really want to go
forward either just because like the
conditions were so terrible so at this
point they were like already starving I
guess it had been I don't know how long
it had been but it's been long enough
that they were like starting to starve
according to him now Packer initially
said that the five guys died of mostly
natural causes just like while they were
going along the trail and then then they
ended up just eating the ones that had
died you know what I'm saying
so he was saying so you'll find them
like at various spots along the trail
because wherever they drop dead from you
know hunger exposure or whatever they
died of and then the rest of us would
eat that guy and then we would keep on
going that was what he claimed and like
I said later on they found out that
that's not what happened but yeah so and
he also said at least one of them had
gone crazy from the hunger and they had
ended up having to kill him because he
was like attacking them so self-defense
again now he said that Israel Swan was
the first one who died he was the oldest
he was 65 years old and he said that he
died only ten days after they had left
the Ute camp and he said that so that
guy died of like natural causes and then
they all ate off him they were already
that hungry
according to him that's what I mean it's
like I don't know the thing about it
though it's an
and I was like thinking about this in
regards to the Donner Party type of
thing you have to think that even though
it doesn't sound like that long like 10
days without eating because I mean a
person can go like durty been a failure
yeah I mean I've I think the person that
went the longest without eating like it
was like three months or some like that
I mean it depends on how much body fat
you have but the thing about it is that
you have to understand how many calories
they were expending yeah like during the
course that they're like yeah they have
food with them when they left they did
but they said that they used it all up
because like I said I don't know well a
presumably dibble it's hard to say
because Packers story was different
every time so I'm not sure entirely what
happened it just didn't seem like it was
long enough for them to be desperate
enough to end up eating people because
that you know in the case of the Donner
Party I mean they I mean these were like
hardcore people they were like stuck in
the [ __ ] snow and all this other kind
of [ __ ] they pretty much exhausted every
other possibility they were eating their
shoes they were eating the oxen [ __ ]
skin they were eating twigs and [ __ ]
like that before they actually like got
around you got around to the people yeah
and they mostly just ate the ones that
died of natural there was a couple
martyrs in there too but they mostly
just ate the people that died of other
things I don't think that was the case
in Packers situation because I think I
don't know if he deliberately set out
saying I'm gonna kill anything
[ __ ] I don't I don't know if he
actually thought that or if they just
got out and it was kind of like hard and
then he was just like [ __ ] I'm just
gonna kill like maybe they really did
run out of food and he was just like
yeah I'm not having this well okay what
are the other store what's the other end
well this is okay so he said Israel Swan
died first he was the oldest one and
then they had all eaten off him then he
said about four or five days later James
Humphrey died and then they ate him too
now he said James Humphrey had a hundred
and thirty three dollars on him which in
today's money is about three grand
so Packer did like confess he's like
I took it because I figured he's dead
and he doesn't mean it anymore so I
might as well take it he did not say how
the other two people in the party
reacted to him taking the money just
because like I said I think this story
is probably largely [ __ ]
now the third guy that died was Frank
Miller I think it was a German and for
whatever reason packer called him the
butcher now he said that Frank Miller
died he was out looking for wood or no
Packer was out looking for wood and
Frank Miller died in an accident
although he didn't specify what the
accident was he said that he was out I
sees like I wasn't even there man and
then Frank Miller dies at the camp and
then he's like and then I came back to
the camp
and the other two guys were already
eating him you know I mean so he said
that he didn't have anything to do with
that um you know so I don't know if he
said that eh because he did say he ate
the other two guys so you know I don't
know why he would be weird about like
eating this a one particular guy but he
just said it wasn't his idea that they
were already eating him when he got back
from looking for what here's the thing
for me that's almost sounding a little
more plausible because it would be
really hard for one guy to overpower
five guys at the same time and eat them
all yeah and I think he had to do it one
at a time
and the first time he did it in a second
they he'd have four three two and one
witness to everything he did yeah so
that means that they were kind of going
along with it you would think that maybe
during this there were other people
involved were like yeah we're going to
eat this guy you know the man yeah okay
we're eat that one it may have been kind
of a group effort because how could one
guy do it yeah he'd have to kill them
all at the same time but something like
a pistol yeah I can see it like that but
eating them one at a time over a certain
period of time and the other ones
tolerating it be hard well I have my own
theories and and you know what do we get
to the end of the story you may like
okay
it will set a new insight into it
because I would think that a peep if the
whole party eats itself it's because
there's more than one person doing it
yeah yes I eat fast yes like it's a
cannibal ah they're all [ __ ] hungry
and then they're turning on the weakest
one and evening yeah and it just keeps
doing that because after a while like
hunger that's like eating that hungry
does make you yeah crazy and as soon but
I start seeing one guy faltering they
might he's gonna think he's gonna be
dead in a few hours let's go ahead and
finish him off and eat yeah and you know
I mean and they might be that's
basically what crickets do in a bait box
yeah you know those crickets run out of
food they started eating each other yeah
nice and they'll just turn on one of him
in a Sonia bite him and he'll be the
weakest one and then they'll start
turning on that one and then they all
eat that one yeah until somebody decides
to bite somebody else and then he
becomes the weak one it's like Oh bill
the cricket said that one was the one we
could eat so let's all eat that one yeah
whoever's injured is the weak one yeah
so yeah so just what one cricket
absolutely take the initial yeah getting
bit and then all sudden they all start
turning on him I kept like I kept
thinking about what I was like watching
some documentaries and [ __ ] like that
about the Donner Party and how they're
saying that you know you know hunger
will actually make you crazy like after
a while like it'll make you go into like
a [ __ ] like feral on [ __ ] it took
quite a long time for that to happen in
the Donner Party that that's why I think
the Packer one I I feel like maybe it
just didn't seem long enough I mean yes
the conditions were bad yes it was
wintertime yes it was the mountains and
stuff but it really seemed like he
resorted to that like maybe more quickly
then I'm not really sure but it's just I
kept thinking about all I can think
about and I'm sorry about this but all I
can think about it's like one of those
Looney Tunes cartoons where like
somebody's really hungry and then they
see somebody walking by and they turn
into a chicken leg or like a moving ham
hock or something right like that's kind
of like what I imagine that it's like
you know what I mean I don't know I've
been very hungry before a lot of times
hunger pain subside and they go away
well it does after a while and
you know them and I've done a lot of
time in the field just [ __ ] haunt you
in the infantry [ __ ] humping around
[ __ ] 40 50 60 pound [ __ ] ruck
sacks along with the m60 and all of the
kind of [ __ ] to Kansa ammo wintertime
too you know with all your [ __ ]
sleeping bags and extreme cold weather
gear you end up in winter you're
carrying your own body weight and at
that time it was probably by one hundred
forty five hundred fifty pounds probably
hundred forty-five pounds probably what
I carried but you would think how could
a person carry a hundred forty you can
you know it's just that it's spread out
over your body so it's not as hard as
you think it it's not like you're
holding it yeah you know but so I know
what it's like you just kind of go numb
it's [ __ ] really cold
you're just beyond exhausted you kind of
just disassociate from your body you're
kind of like eyeballs you just feel like
your eyeballs eyeballs walking around in
the woods but if you got hungry you'd
start to get weak and you'd probably
have I would think that they were
probably sleeping a lot though - it
depends on how much they were moving
they were on foot I absolutely I assumed
that they were on foot they might have
been on horseback white horses that's a
horse I don't think that they were
though because like I said I don't ever
see I've never seen any mention the
clear horses for them to because in
general it's a death sentence to be
walking around out in the West
especially back then and in the
wintertime in the mountains and it
wasn't like nowadays where like a lot of
the trails are like mapped or like
people know where they go it's like back
then everybody's like yeah we think
maybe just that way well they were
called in an expedition maybe they were
just wrecking it they just had [ __ ]
rucksack so on
yeah I mean there was only six of them
so I don't know why they weren't
carrying mules do you at least you'd
think they'd have mules with them like
to carry the carrier [ __ ] [ __ ] again and
you can eat mules
it just seemed really ill-advised video
well because like I said when they went
to they had already been having problems
when they got to the Ute camp in January
and the guy was like man it's like
wintertime you probably stay here until
spring because otherwise you're gonna be
hosed out there in the thing but they
just went anyway and it seems like they
didn't take enough stuff yeah you years
mention of rifles right well they well
they had guns I don't know about rifles
but I think I know for sure that Packer
had a revolver at least because you know
you're gonna want to carry a little 30
caliber 20 well yeah I mean in case
you're loading rifles so you can eat
yeah
squirrel you know and I presume that
they were all armed because they said
that they did try to hunt for a game but
there just wasn't much of it around I
just seemed a second but like I said
your this is only coming from Alfred
Packer and he has a vested interest in
not necessarily telling people what
actually happened to make himself look
better winter time in the mountains
there'd still be squirrels and birds and
you know I mean it's not lifeless out
there I don't know what the water
situation was they must have been around
water because they weren't carrying it
well I don't know if they were carrying
water you can fish you know there's
still fish no he said that they were
going to try and fish but he said the
lakes and [ __ ] were frozen over just
break the top of it it was like a bad
yeah well well a similar thing happened
with with the Donner Party one of the
problems that they had to I mean they
really got [ __ ] on my life I'm actually
surprised any of them survived after
listening to the litany of Horrors that
they had to go through but the problem
with what happened with the Donner Party
was that that winter was really really
bad like some of the lakes were frozen
all the way down they were frozen solid
so it wasn't just a kind of a case where
you just cut a hole in the ice or [ __ ]
like that there was nothing it was just
frozen all the way down because it was
like a really really severe pension they
were frozen fish down in there probably
but you know Howard - prior to we you
couldn't get to it yeah because at that
point you're so weak that they couldn't
do much of anything you got to stay
strong when you're out there you can't
wait till you get weak once you're weak
you're dead well yeah when you're out
there especially with the cold you know
like in Korea be 40 50 degrees below
zero at night insanely [ __ ] cold
we're out there in sleeping bags
you know we had extreme cold weather
bags but still it's just not enough at
that temperature yeah sometimes it has
walking through the whole night I think
to keep us from [ __ ] dying yeah
because as long as you stay
moving and you got the right gear on you
won't die yeah as soon as you stay as
soon as you stop you probably will at
that temperature yeah I would imagine
yeah 50 45 - 45 to 50 degrees below zero
insanely cold yeah it's just like it was
traumatic traumatic for me
and that was my first time going in the
field there's team spirit man the team
spirit that's the you know how they're
always talking about the annual war
games that pisses off North Korea mm-hmm
that's team spirit yeah my first time
going into the field was with team
spirit with the 506 and all the veteran
guys that were there were [ __ ] tisk
tisk in because we were there was like
about 40 knew of 40 new troops that I
got that we all came into the unit at
the same time they were my basic
training platoon we all [ __ ] blended
in with this new unit and they were just
[ __ ] pity in us you guys [ __ ] suck
you weak you guys aren't gonna make it
you're that gonna [ __ ] boy your first
field problem tea spirit you guys are
[ __ ] soft as [ __ ] all you guys are
[ __ ] you know and it was true man we
were [ __ ] we were eight the [ __ ] up
that [ __ ] was traumatic yeah yeah I
never forget it that [ __ ] was [ __ ]
terrible yeah no thanks first time I go
to field I got hung out and they made me
a 60 gutter because they said you're the
rock they said I was your you're the
rock of the [ __ ] we're gonna go ahead
and get this over with
[ __ ] send you back to McDonald's
where you flip burgers that pissed me
off of course there's no way I was gonna
fail after that gave me that [ __ ] m16
[ __ ] man is cold bad yeah and the first
time the first movement we run off the
truck 18 kilometers across the [ __ ]
mountains before we have bedded down it
was [ __ ] it it was all night Walker
even the old guys were pissed off anyway
I don't like it but I know if they know
what he's talking about it's just that
the difference was is that in a military
situation you're driven to show up at a
certain place by a certain time you have
to make it there these guys don't have
to make it so they could have changed
course and got into a better place where
they could survive or you know did
take him to the side of he'll make a
shelter you know start making a
permanent camp to camp out through the
winter find a location but he's not
talking like that see that's what I kind
of see I kind of feel like he I don't
know if he planned this exactly from the
beginning but I don't know if he planned
to like eat them and [ __ ] like that but
I do think he was planning something
nefarious even from like when they he
was just kind of like man I'm just gonna
wait and kill these dudes and then maybe
the fact that it's like oh they ran out
of food he's like well might as well eat
him since I already shot him I kind of
feel like that sounds like it got hard
got rough out there yeah and he buckled
and said [ __ ] it I'm gonna kill these
dudes so I can live yeah I kind of feel
I think that's what happened yeah and it
was freezing out there so you could kill
them all at once yeah they would stay
frozen like I said I suspect that that's
probably what happened yeah like I said
I'll get it he ate frozen meat deer net
during that winter how much I bet yeah
I'm sure you did yeah so so as I said he
said that he wasn't there for the
killing of Frank Miller but that that
Frank Miller died in an accident while
he was out gathering wood and he came
back and the other two guys were already
eating him so the next one that died was
the 18 year old boy George California
noon Packer again said that he wasn't
there for this [ __ ] which to me this
just seems like he's like I wasn't even
there I just came back and this [ __ ] was
happening it just sounds very very
implausible to me he said he had gone
off away from the camp for a couple of
days because he was like looking for
game and like hunting and stuff and he
said when he got back to the camp that
Belle had shot the 18 year old boy using
Israel swans gun so he's like he I don't
think he said like why did that happen
but he said so he's like I did eat the
kid but I wasn't there like Belle shot
him
so only packer and Belle are left at
this point now according to packer he
said that after they had
Eitan the kid that Bell decided that he
was gonna kill packer this is what
packer said so packer of course decides
I'm gonna kill Bell in self-defense
right he says that Bell like swung his
rifle at him and all this other kind of
shits their rifles yeah they did all
right so and they they said so the
packer was the only one left so when he
got back he said that's that's
absolutely what happened whole truth
nothing but the truth so help me God he
swore he signed it and everything like
that I got a feeling that these dudes
embarked on this damn expedition with no
field experience or very little field
experience for a winter how much wrong
bad they just didn't know what they were
getting into well it does seem dumb that
they only took 10 days worth of
provisions for six guys yeah I mean
enough like I said even I mean they
thought that it was only 40 miles but
still I mean you would take extra it did
end up being like 75 miles apparently
like where they were actually going to
but said 10 days supplies for six guys
good to go 40 miles that just I don't
know it just doesn't seem like I don't
know how much that is but it just
doesn't seem like very much to me you
know what I'm saying like for the winter
time yeah cuz you're not gonna be in
days yeah you're not gonna make very
good time I wonder I wonder what they
considered to be one days of supplies
that's what I was kind of wondering I'm
not entirely sure like what they would
consider because as I said it has to do
with well how much how many calories are
you planning on burning that day like
are you you know walking are you on
horseback are you climbing Matthew I've
heard you I've never carried 10 days
worth of MREs more than I don't think
I've ever carried any more in about four
yeah so how much bulk are they talking
well yeah and like it was different back
then
well yeah back then were they talking
about a time bomb panic in are they
talking about jerky are they talking
about coffee sometimes they say well
coffee is a supply that's a ration well
yeah they always like they thought that
was a food that was a coffee was a food
group it definitely was yeah bang I
don't know
stand that there's no calories they're
not really coffee has very very few has
no nutritional value no so you got to
figure that they're out there with some
inferior ass [ __ ] because the eighteen
hundred's they didn't really know much
about nutrition yeah they should they
best thing that the best thing to have
for any kind of survival ration back
then would have been jerky and pemmican
yeah you could kind of live on that I
was reading an article the other day
about making your own pemmican yeah
dudes might have been kind of dumb they
might have been trying to live off of
coffee in tobacco and maybe hardtack
yeah yeah I mean which hard tag that's
just damn [ __ ] flour flour and water
we'll see that's what I'm kind of
thinking that because when I was reading
about the Donner Party um like a lot of
they took a lot of flour with them and
I'm guessing that's why I like to make
heart attack there's no [ __ ]
nutritional value yeah no but it's like
Dana I don't think they really know
anything about that they didn't have
like [ __ ] nutritionists and [ __ ] like
that yeah they just what you can eat it
then it keeps you alive
yeah no it's not that's not what the
deals not exactly try to live off
[ __ ] ramen I tried it one time when I
was [ __ ] poor yeah there's no
nutrition in there you get [ __ ] sick
quick yeah I mean you're gonna get like
all kind of vitamin deficiency I think
back and back in those days they'd I
don't think they understood that concept
like you said if it was food then they
kept you alive then all food was equally
yeah good you know what I mean it is
hella concept a protein or that you
needed like a variety of things like to
keep you from getting sick right they
didn't you know it's good they knew
about scurvy by this the point they did
yeah but I heard that you had a citrus
some kind of citrus but there was you
could sidestep that though a few you
know well pemmican kind of had citrus
tea type stuff in it yeah and yeah it's
just it makes me wonder they must have
been very poorly equipped I kind of got
that feeling like I said it almost seems
like a half-ass like a last minute
because all the other guys that had come
to the Ute camp with them cuz there was
like 20 guys
well 21 guys originally most of them
didn't go most of them stayed at the
camp over like yeah we're totally gonna
wait till springtime because that's not
the intelligent thing to do but it's
just these six guys decided to just like
[ __ ] go off and yeah so I'm sitting
here I'm kinda making a moral judgement
on the dude based on my experiences with
going to the field in the infantry but
my experiences are clouded because I was
given good rations yeah see you know our
ears are [ __ ] bad-ass well that would
you know especially compared to what
these dudes are probably eating and you
have to think too that you had like
modern moving and clutter and shoes
right so they went out there and they in
the elements just whip that ass it beat
that ass when they were out there which
if you don't have the right [ __ ] it will
do that to anyone and nature hates you
and then they're trying to [ __ ] live
off of some [ __ ] 1800 survival
[ __ ] rations that probably had no
nutritional value yeah and they bought
it just because that's what they sold
them when they went to the damn trading
bus oh yeah you can make it on that here
here
Bartek here here here's some tobacco
here's some [ __ ] coffee
oh yeah that's all you need you got all
the major focus and then they get out
there you know what I mean they wonder
why they're [ __ ] sucking so bad I'm so
tired why missed a week what you know
man
hammy someone at cha yes they're chewing
tobacco and spitting out all their water
all their fluids and dehydrated and that
really starts [ __ ] with your mind you
know I mean so they're in a delirium I
can see how okay if through dehydration
exhaustion and malnutrition and they
just [ __ ] lose it and start eating
each other
yeah well one of them loses its and it
loses it and decides to eat the rest of
them because you know winning with life
you know their life will find a way
that's a drastic part life will find a
way and that's what happens you know
biology is powerful people want to live
and maybe just dude [ __ ] lost it he
just started I won't get me some protein
he started seeing all the little guys
it's like a little chicken legs bouncing
around in the snow right just like that
thinking that's probably what we're
talking about here that that was the
motive or that was the situation I I
kind of suspect that he was considering
killing them from the beginning like
just to rob them and then when [ __ ] got
hard and they ran out of stuff he's like
well might as well eat him too like
while I'm at it I just kind of feel like
that's maybe I don't know there's I
don't think he was intending to eat them
from the start but I think he was
intending to like rob them for sure well
okay and maybe kill him
I'm thinking it's more I'm thinking it's
more likely that one thing led to
another
yeah he was good on the expedition but
they know nobody we they really started
to suffer because they just were
ill-equipped he decided to eat him then
they had money yeah so you keep the
money yeah cuz he's like well then and
then afterwards when you're a little bit
better fed you kind of come to your
senses you know go [ __ ] yeah I better
think of feeling there some [ __ ] like
that
you know to me yeah probably not talking
about a real high IQ dude in the unit to
begin with anyway there he'd have been
up in the middle class somewhere [ __ ]
out in Wellesley Massachusetts you know
with his family and his little wagon and
[ __ ] and [ __ ] you know working at the
local grocery store you know but that's
not who you're talking about here no
you're talking about probably dude came
from the hood yeah so I can see it yeah
I can see it yes probably you know you
dealing with like River Phoenix from
that damn [ __ ] western movie that he
was in that's what you're talking about
what was the name of that movie
yeah that western movies I saw had West
[ __ ] Phoenix in us before the joke
that came out you played that [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] dude from the Wild West
it's about two brothers it's about two
brothers never doing so we saw the
theater he wasn't a bad movie just
didn't make a big impression yeah yeah
but I'm just kind of getting a feel for
what who these guys are
that's probably what it was yeah so he
comes back and tells him this story and
like I said he signed it and everything
he's like this is exactly what happened
I promise so so they sent out a search
party now according to Alfred Packers
story
all the guys were killed at different
times which would lead you to assume
that they would find their body in five
different places yeah they were moving
of course you know so he's like okay
well I'll take you to where I think
where I last saw them and then we'll see
if we can find the bodies however the
search party could not locate any of the
bodies now so when they get back to cig
watch a they decide to arrest him on
suspicion of murder because the
authorities didn't believe this story
either yeah okay
so August of 1874 which you know was a
few months afterward there was an artist
for Harper's Weekly magazine he had been
sent out to you know do a [ __ ] do
some drawings or [ __ ] like that and he
was going across the wonderfully named
slum galleon pass and he found five sets
of human remains laying all together in
a cluster near the bank of the lake Fork
of the Gunnison River yeah well that
tells you right all together and
apparently the drawing that he did which
is actually quite famous because he sat
there like drew cuz they didn't have
like you know cameras weren't all that
widespread or anything so he
that there and drew it it's a pretty
grisly looking you could still most of
them are recognizable one of them didn't
have a head they later found out that
that was Frank Miller the butcher just
from process of elimination because they
could recognize all the other ones but
they had clearly been killed and
defleshed in places like some of them
like they still had the face but then
like all the meat was gone off their leg
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so you
think they were killed what move
gunshots it's hard to tell because some
of the it did appear that at least one
of them had something that looked like a
gunshot some of the bones apparently had
holes in them but they weren't sure if
it was bullet holes or if it was just
like from animals or if it was some
other thing you know what I mean it was
kind of hard to tell so they also found
among these five bodies which like I
said we're still recognizable more or
less as the prospectors they found like
a bunch of torn clothing some blankets
some shreds of human flesh but you know
it had been several months so the
weather you know the elements animals
stuff like that and eaten part of them
so that was kind of like all torn up and
they weren't really sure like how they
had been left you know what I mean now
apparently their feet had been like
bound up in blankets so I'm assuming
that I don't know if they like ate their
shoes and so they like wrapped blankets
around their feet at some point because
they found that's what I'm kind of
figured because that happened the Donner
parties well they ended up happily eat
their shoes and whatnot but they didn't
find any guns they didn't find any
cooking utensils like to call that they
didn't find any of their shoes yet as I
said one of the sets of remains was
missing the head two of the bodies had
pieces of flesh cut out one had been
taken out of like the chest area and one
out of the thigh one of the bodies there
were like a bunch of marks left on it
that clearly looked as though this
person had put up a fight so this is not
a case of like these people died of
accident
they just died of like exposure or
whatever and then oh well we I guess
we'd better eat them this looked like
somebody murdered at least this one
person and they were defeat were wrapped
up on those bodies in that spot right
there would ya okay so were they living
there and killed there in other words
like was that their camp I'm not leaving
they said it was hard to tell because
they didn't find like they found clothes
and [ __ ] but they didn't find like any
pots and pans or anything like that
would suggest that that was that there
was a fire there or anything not that I
ever heard name removed there perhaps
yeah how much you wanna bet he got
desperate and he was like we're all
gonna die because they were eating shoes
and doing [ __ ] like that so he said [ __ ]
it he went for his gun while they were
asleep we started gunning them down so
I'm gonna eat him and get enough
strength I'm gonna take all this [ __ ]
see that's what I kind of figured
probably what happened because like I
said obviously the second story that he
told was [ __ ] because he said that
they all died at different times and
then they just ended up eating them he
killed them all but he killed him all at
once because they found them all
together the more likely scenario is
that they were at a camp and they were
[ __ ] holed up in that camp they were
desperate maybe like one or two of them
were too sick to move or frostbite and
couldn't move and the and the party was
bogged down
he realized [ __ ] we're just gonna sit
here and starve to death and die you
know maybe one by one and probably have
to eat each other
one by one and he's thinking about and
he goes [ __ ] if I just kill them all
I'll eat them all right now
yeah and then I'll get the strength to
walk out of here that's I think that's
probably that's probably yeah
so you know what in a way that in a
situation like that that might have been
the right decision although like I said
I don't know how bad it was like if it
was actually bad at earth he just
decided he was just gonna jump the gun
and be like [ __ ] it I'm just gonna kill
all these people because they were all
so alive and they were all dying though
maybe they were I don't know but you he
was dying Bart
and then a couple of other rooms were
too sick to move and then the other ones
were dying and they were thinking they
were all thinking about was [ __ ] when
these sick ones die we'll eat them
yeah but then the next logical step was
as you know like well not allowed not a
lot of food to go around we'll just sit
here until another one will get sick and
then we'll eat that one and then
eventually get down just one guy yeah
starving to death sitting here with
these dead bodies so he's the one
thinking about that he's cuz you know
what I could jump the gun though yeah if
I kill them all you know cuz we're all
gonna die anyway but if I kill these
guys I have plenty of food I'll eat them
all over a period of a couple days
regain my strength I'll pick up I'll
take all this [ __ ] I'll go back home
yeah I think that's exactly what that's
probably happened I think I might've
solved it and then after he'll I think
that's what most people think yeah and
then and that's just not what he said
happens yeah he was trying to hide it
yeah I didn't want people to know that
that was the decision that he made hmm
which in a situation like that that may
have been the right decision had he not
done that there probably sit there one
by one starved to death needed each
other yeah bogged it down it's probably
because it might have been the
psychology of the situation the guys
that he was with maybe they were kind of
like guys that were too - starving - out
of their mind to make rational decisions
ya know so you couldn't stay you had to
leave I mean that's our tough call I'd
have to see what the situation was
that's what I mean and no one no one
knows what the situation was other than
him yeah I bet you they would none of
them were in a shape to move maybe not
and I bet you he wasn't in the shape to
move I bet they were all about [ __ ]
out of their minds I bet you at least
one of them was getting ready to die so
they couldn't leave him hide yeah you
know they were probably talking about
eating and him went when he did die yeah
but but by the time that one was dead
and eaten chances are another one would
have been ready to die - and then
another one ready to die because they
were all deteriorating yeah and that's
not enough food at once to gain any
strength but if you had five bodies you
could sit there and [ __ ]
eat them all and over a period of a few
days get strong enough to walk back out
of there long pig eating that long pig
but yeah that long pig no black people
say white people smell like Bologna I
don't know if they smell like blowing
but they might taste like Bologna yeah
we probably do j-money people yeah yeah
roughly yeah I mean it depends on the
person I guess so like what their diet
is used to hang I haven't eaten Bologna
since I was a kid I used to hang out
with this dude he was the [ __ ] what's
called a hotel and he was kind of like
it's kind of like Black Liberation
Theology he's real [ __ ] he liked but
he didn't like even like white people he
liked me though bad we would sit there
and [ __ ] each other all the time and
said he's like he got y'all [ __ ]
cave-dwellers smell like Bologna calling
me king of dwellers seeing that I was
made by a [ __ ] ancient Egyptian
scientist and [ __ ] you know yeah yeah
yeah yeah he's going through all that I
don't play I play games of this dude
[ __ ] all [ __ ] day and yeah you know I
just just I don't know what it was you
know man I would just [ __ ] resonate
with the dude it's [ __ ] fun areas for
that doesn't surprise me
that sounds like the type of dude that
you it is yeah
cuz you have a lot of common he was
[ __ ] funny man there he was fine why
[Applause]
they might be ho tips out there
listening right now man as she was
[ __ ] you never know yeah do I smell
evil in your white devil smelling like
[ __ ] Bologna maybe we do I don't know
it would make sense like I said it's
don't don't cannibal say they came in
tastes like work that I think all
whomping yeah well and I heard something
worth more did I hear this earlier I
don't even remember but apparently
someone who's like an EMT or something
and they deal with like burn victims
yeah they said I don't want to be
indelicate but humans they it's kind of
smell like barbecue
yeah like when you get like a yeah a
burn victim and stuff and I'm like well
if he's true we're just meat you know
can't get too wrapped up I think I think
maybe dude just made a [ __ ] command
in a pitch yeah I think he thought that
everybody was gonna die so he's gonna go
ahead and [ __ ] kill all these dudes
yeah well you have enough [ __ ]
strength to walk out of there afterwards
anybody couldn't explain it so what
ended up happening was that I mean cuz I
still have like quite a bit to go on
this case so I'm trying to like journey
kids because we're gonna have to like
take a break in a minute because it's
more than an hour but so they find the
five bodies also they know that Alfred
Packers story is [ __ ] because he
said they were all scattered all over
and they found them obviously all
together and they'd all been murdered or
at least one of them had been murdered
because he looked like he'd struggled so
they're like that [ __ ] so they
go back to segue and they're gonna like
confirm him with this like hey we know
you're full of [ __ ] and when he got back
they figured out that he had escaped
from jail yeah and so they didn't find
him for quite a while yeah so we will
get into that in a minute
we're probably gonna take a break
because I think it's over an hour yes it
is but here's the thing if we take the
break now you'll be able to wrap it up
because we got to do the Donner Party
too
well I know but you know okay it's gonna
be no three and a half hour for the show
well hey whose fault is that it's your
fault yours you're chosen to you should
know you're choosing to you're giving
them two topics yeah - that's okay you
ain't [ __ ] unlike all these tangents
that's that's like a really that's my
[ __ ] job so it's like not mine I
would have been appreciated yeah I would
have been through the [ __ ] like a long
time ago if you hadn't kept going off on
all this stuff but yeah this is what I
deal with okay this is what I deal with
I'm like just I'm trying to get back on
topic and you're just gonna okay I mean
like I said people like when these shows
are long okay I'm just saying like don't
blame me because this isn't really that
long a topic it's just that well I'm
okay well I gotta finish this that's
what I'm saying
okay and then you have to go you have to
go refill that and you'll find the kitty
cuz I think she's okay backwards but
yeah so Alfred Packer escaped from jail
and they didn't find him for a little
while but when we come back we will talk
about what happened when he came back
like the trials that he went through and
stuff like that and then we will talk
also about the horrible horrible
horrific story of the Donner Party and
how they
ended up having to eat each other up as
Danny or it says yeah so we will be back
in just a couple of minutes love and
honest to do lights huh lick your booty
okay light that DMX
on a break in between segments of the
show
don't do it poopy don't do it don't do
it that's gain the light where you going
where you going where you going
you love true crime I love true crime
and I've spent the last three years
compiling a series of the most
intriguing unsolved murders of the 20th
century it's called the faceless villain
and volume three is available now
featuring such fascinating cases as the
Caddy murders the carry baby's case the
frog boys the al-qasr murders and the
inokashira park dismemberment incident
the faithless villain volume three is an
involving exploration of unsolved slang
spanning the years from 1980 to 1999
pick up your copy and print or eBook
formats on Amazon or download the
audiobook version from audible.com and
get ready for a chilling journey through
modern crime history
all right we're back on this frontier
cannibalism show yeah talk about a
little Alfred Packer yeah I asked Jenny
so having his left on this case and she
goes I don't know as much as left as his
left yeah so she said as a guard he's
got a long shot as much as his left it's
like as I would have been done if you
hadn't like got off on like several long
tangents promise you know no I have
another topic [ __ ] it [ __ ] it okay I can
say that it's just gonna be the Jenny
show well I mean you can say stuff it's
just like sometimes you go but then you
like complain because I'm like you know
I still have like a lot of stuff I have
to talk about all right you know that's
all I'm saying so why don't we last left
a little Alfred hacker don't you laugh
at me okay all right well we last left
old Alfred Packer he had escaped from
jail they didn't find his ass for nine
long years no one really knows what he
was doing all that time like to make
money or anything like that I presume it
was crime but they do know that he was
operating under a pseudonym John Schwarz
yeah my name too
yeah well the stupid thing though is
that how he got found like he was in
like Arizona and he was like going like
other places but then for whatever
reason he came back to Wyoming and he
was in a saloon and a guy named Frenchy
Cabazon was in the saloon and he had
been on the original he was part of the
original 21 guys of the first expedition
that had gone to it and he recognized
Alfred Packers laughs from across the
saloon and everybody knew that he was
wanted right
so frenchie like reported him to the
police so no one is quite sure why
Alfred Packer if he was trying to evade
the authorities why he came back
to a place where people knew him that he
seemed like a good thing to do maybe not
nine years been at a vintage a long time
in those days it was hard to prove
anything and that's true and there's a
lot of transient population so back in
those days you know he figured [ __ ]
he was long forgotten no he was
incorrect
yeah so where they caught him was only
300 miles from the prison where he'd
escaped from like I said and he had been
- like he said later that he had been in
like Arizona and he'd been like far away
they don't really know why he came back
maybe you wanted to get caught or like
he said he was arrogant and he just
thought oh they forgot about me by now
it had been nine years so but they had
not forgotten about him and he got
arrested the he got put before a grand
jury who returned five indictments
against him for the hatchet murders of
the five other guys because I guess they
determined that that's how he killed him
with a hatchet instead of I mean I think
one of them had a gun shot but I'm not
really sure about the other ones hatchet
yeah so at this point he gives yet
another version of events what is this
the third one now you're right so this
is what he says nine years later he says
now yeah we left the camp the Ute camp
and we only had seven days worth of
supplies for one dude and there's six
guys on this [ __ ] thing so I don't
know what the [ __ ] they were thinking
but initially they said it was ten you
know ten days worth now he said it was
only seven days worth and that was only
for one person so he says two or three
days into the exhibition and into the
expedition there was a snowstorm and the
snow was so deep that they couldn't get
through it and he said they went through
all their provisions really fast by the
fourth day all they had left with some
flour but they still kept on going
so he's like they're eatin like [ __ ]
plants off of [ __ ] like you know gum and
stuff off their boots and [ __ ] like that
you know and they started he said that
everybody started getting real like
acting kind of loopy cuz they were
really hungry and stuff like that even
though it's only been a couple days so
I'm like whatever he did say that they
found a lake and they tried to fish like
they
cut holes in the ice but they didn't
catch anything at this point he said
that Israel Swan started to you know
lose it and kind of like freak out and
stuff
he told Alfred according to Alfred to go
up the mountain with his rifle and like
scout out the terrain can we go that way
and [ __ ] like that because Alfred was
saying well at this point I was like you
know the head of the expedition I was
like the guide or whatever um so he goes
up to scout and he says all he sees is
snow and you know they don't know where
they're gonna go from here they're
totally lost like the weather is really
bad and he said that Bell had been
acting like a nutcase just because they
were all so hungry and he was starting
to lose it and [ __ ] like that
so then Alfred says that he came back to
the camp to tell them hey dudes were
kind of [ __ ] and at this point he says
Bell had already killed Frank Miller the
butcher and was eating part of his leg
so again he's trying to allay some of
the suspicion from his himself by saying
hey I wasn't even here I was out doing
some useful [ __ ] and I just got back and
dude it was like that when I got here
that's basically what he's saying so I'm
not either well like I said this is like
the third version of the story that he's
given at this point and he will give
another one like before the [ __ ] thing
so he says that he comes up to the fire
and that Bell then picked up a hatchet
and attacked him and then Packer said
well he shot him in the stomach and then
he said bail fell onto the hatchet
Alfred picked it up and then hit him
like on the top of the head and like
killed him with the hatchet then he said
he was all bummed out about it because
of course this is like a very
self-serving narrative he says that at
this point all the other four were like
four of them were dead and he was like
gonna leave the camp because he felt so
bad or whatever and he said that he
tried to bury them or like he covered
them snow or whatever and but that he
eat off of the bodies that that the
other guy had already like prepared you
know what I mean so he said that well I
kept trying to leave but the snow was so
bad so I had to like just eat more of
them you know like as the time went on
yeah and he said he lived this way for
two months because he can only eat a
little bit of human flesh at a time he
said finally there was a thaw so he
packed up some of the flesh one of the
guns $70 which in today's money is about
1,600 bucks and just started going back
to the Indian agency or whatever in
Colorado now he said that he ate the
last of the meat on his way back to the
camp
however if you'll remember you know when
he first came back they found like
scraps of human meat like along the
trail so he couldn't really explain like
why they why he left like scraps of
human meat along if he said that he ate
it all like on the way back so again
this is another version of the story
that doesn't sound super plausible now
he did admit he said you you know you
remember when we had that search party
and I told you that I was gonna tell you
where the bodies were cuz I at that
point I was saying that they were all
spread out and they weren't all in one
place even though that's the way they
found them he said well I didn't know
where they were but I didn't want you
guys to find him so I just like
pretended like I legit to a different
place or not far enough or like you know
I didn't want you finding the actual
bodies so he also said that he had
escaped from the jail previously by
using a pen knife and like using that
like in a keyhole like kind of Jimmy in
the lock and that he had been in Arizona
and Arkansas and that had finally
returned to Wyoming where he was heard
by a former colleague of his now this
was yet another confession that he swore
up and down was true he signed it and
everything so they put him on trial for
murder in April of 1883 now this was
only the murder of Israel Swann one of
the dudes because that was the guy he
was the oldest guy he was the only body
that very clearly had
signs of like a hand-to-hand struggle
you know what I'm saying so they knew
that his death had been violent and he
had like fought his killer the dumb
thing is that even though Packer said
that he had shot one of the dudes in
self-defense
that wasn't even Israel Swann that he
said he shot in self-defense he said
that he shots Bell in self-defense he
didn't say anything about Swann you know
what I mean so they thought it a little
weird that like it looked like Israel's
wanted fought somebody like and then got
him killed that's a fabricated story
yeah it is yeah
so they used like I said they didn't
have any photographs of the scene but
they did have this very detailed
illustration that this guy from Harper's
Weekly had done so and they were all
very close together like I've seen the
illustration so they said all but one of
the bodies had hatchet wounds to the
head and all like it looked like the
backs of the heads were like mashed in
like he had just maybe he done it when
they were sleeping I'm gonna show them
yeah like the one of the guys fought
back obviously but that was the only guy
that you know had evidence that he had
actually fought back so the weird thing
is that [ __ ] the Alfred Packer took
the stand in his own defense which
probably was not the wisest move they
said that he was on the stand for about
two hours and a lot of the [ __ ] that he
said on the stand was obviously not true
because he contradicted himself like
several times he lied about other things
too like just about his past like about
how old he was like he lied about his
military service all of a sudden kinda
stuff because he had been in the
military but he was discharged a couple
times I believe because he had epilepsy
so he had gotten kicked out because of
that but he made up [ __ ] about that that
they later found out wasn't true so he
also um he came across as very in the
sense that like you know people that are
like pathological liars and they kind of
come across as like overconfident or
little condescending or so he kind of
came across like that so I feel like the
jury not
only do they not by what he was saying
because he contradicted himself but also
because he kind of came off as a douche
so they didn't really you know they
weren't really feeling it um so
basically he's trying to is a very
self-serving confession where he's
basically had an excuse for everything
it's like you know I came back to the
camp and they had already killed the
person and we're eating them or I killed
the person in self-defense it was always
he was never entirely responsible like
yeah I killed the [ __ ] and ate
him even though I'm pretty sure that
that's what's happened
he always had an excuse that it wasn't
his fault you know what I'm saying he
always kind of had most likely that they
were all in trouble yeah and he was the
first one to break unit cohesion he says
I'm gonna kill all these dudes and eat
him yeah so I could get out of here
killed him and killed him what tried to
kill him in their sleep with a [ __ ]
hatchet yeah one of them woke up during
oh yeah the old guy walk around like
you're not taking me a lot of money yeah
that's probably what happened I kind of
feel because they were all I mean Roomba
sketch the the bodies were right there
they were all very close together now
how much in trouble were they hard to
say did they really only take seven days
worth of food for one guy for six men
could be what you're talking about you
talking about like now you're talking
about a pathological liar type dude yeah
he definitely does him and I was like
and he's one of those they tend to be
weak
chances are the party probably wasn't as
bad off as he thought it was see that's
what I was suspected because they hadn't
been gone that long how much you want to
bet it was bad but it was kind of under
control that in the other suspect and
the other guys had enough experience to
get through it but he [ __ ] lost his
[ __ ] mm-hmm and said we're all gonna die
you know but if I kill all these dudes I
can live and that and he well done he
lost him he lost his nerve and went out
there and [ __ ] you know I mean and
[ __ ] killed him with a [ __ ]
hatchet yeah and all this [ __ ] about him
betting down or camping down that's
[ __ ] he took all of flesh he could
off those bodies and
when he took it off yeah he packed that
up and [ __ ] walked around walked back
with it eating it the whole way yeah
getting fat how much you out of it
well yeah because I think when he got
back in town they did say that he looked
like fairly healthy and he had all the
supplies that were uneaten - yeah yeah
and I bet you he had all the guns yeah
and probably sold them off yeah yeah I
imagine he probably did because like I
said when he turned up at you know the
that whatever center that was in
Colorado he loved it
well know what I was gonna say was that
yeah you know he had as far as I know he
had one gun he had a bunch of money and
[ __ ] like that however people had seen
him in town like in a saloon or
something like that like a week
previously so he might have come into
town much earlier and then kept it on
the DL and you serve going around like
cash and [ __ ] in and like genuine to
some evidence and eating up some of that
meat yeah that's why I mean because they
did find some human meat along the trail
even though he said that he'd eaten it
all on the way back no I bet you he had
that [ __ ] in town was eating it - yeah I
kind of suspect like I said I it's hard
to say because you know everything he
said yeah everything he said was pretty
much a lie yeah but I mean I'm sure
there's a kernel of truth to it but I
definitely do think that he just like
killed all this I think the cold blood I
think the party was in trouble but it
but no in as much trouble as he thought
it was like right not as much trouble as
he thought it was he was in serious
trouble
because he was [ __ ] out of his depth
how much wrong bit yeah the other guys
were more used to it yeah and they were
like yeah we'll make it and he yeah
it'll be all right Alfred yeah he's like
nah we're all starving to death you know
what I mean and this is that this isn't
a Uruguayan rugby players such a we
might have been something like that you
know yeah but so I wrapped up feet and
everything I don't know maybe it was but
I mean it was cold it just seems to me
that like maybe that's maybe they're
reading into it too much maybe they he
stole their boots and they were dead
and it just happened to be that there
was some [ __ ] wrapped around there you
know that's what yeah I mean the first
thing you would think was that oh they
ate their shoes and they had to like
wrap blankets around their feet maybe
you just stole their boots
yeah maybe cuz boots weren't worth a lot
of money back well yeah so I mean boots
are important maybe your house been
around it could be he packed the boots
up and packed those in a [ __ ] rock he
could have done that while they were
sleeping too right he's like I don't
know like some [ __ ] like it goes dead
yeah after he killed her he would have
taken anything of value yeah
and you know and hiked that back to a
town where he could sell it yeah so it
could be that the party wasn't in that
much trouble they weren't eating boots
actually there's not enough time of it
has it like what that's what I'm saying
it's like the time period that elapsed
it's like yes they it was two months
from the time that they set out to the
time that he came back but he's saying
even according to his tale which I don't
know like you would think that he would
make it a longer period of time but
maybe he wasn't that bright I mean he
was saying that by the fourth day they
were out of food no and they were
getting super desperate and I'm like and
you seem by the tenth day they're eating
boots right yeah it's like you didn't
know I mean I know that it's like yeah
it's really cold and you got a week for
no progress what I mean it's like not
really that big a deal to go for that
long a time without eating it's not fun
I wouldn't recommend it but you're not
gonna die
necessarily you know what I'm saying so
most of those dudes knew the ways of the
[ __ ] forest yeah all right they could
get somebody even if it meant [ __ ]
digging up [ __ ] bugs in the winter
you know there's a lot of they have
little ways yeah yeah to supplement
their their their diet yeah I just don't
I'm just not really buying it no I'm not
either it's not enough time now if he's
telling me you know six weeks into it
they're eating boots maybe see that's
what that's what we're it's me out it's
like you know he's obviously lying yeah
three weeks into it maybe four weeks
yeah so it's like if he was just making
up the story you would think that he
would lengthen the amount of time and
saying
yeah we hadn't eaten for like a month
and then I feel like he maybe would have
gotten more sympathy but the fact that
he's just saying it was just like a few
days yeah because any idiot knows that
in winter time you're now surviving
without boots how are you gonna walk
back without boots yeah your toes will
fall off if [ __ ] fall off with it in
an hour you know you got frostbite
within an hour
yep and then you walk on them and they
[ __ ] break off pop pop you know I
mean within a few hours frostbite and
those dudes have to know that you know I
mean so they weren't eating boots that
that you know I mean that soon that
would be like one of the last that would
be the last I mean like I said even the
Donner Party that was one of the very
last resort of the cannibalism that was
one of the very last things yeah you
know [ __ ] he stole their boots that's
adopted that would not shock me like he
stole all their other [ __ ] do ya might
as well have boots don't weigh that much
you can fold them roll them up and
they're worth money yeah so yeah and
like I said I suspect that he came back
into town earlier than he said yeah and
like cash this possum pawn and [ __ ]
selling stuff and that is kind of what
I'm some of that stuff was boots yeah
all they're like supplies and other guns
and right guns boots because all of them
had firearms and so and as far as I know
he only came back with one or maybe two
right Oh what happened to the other ones
yeah those right I didn't find any at
the campsite so he obviously took them
right but so yeah so he got convicted in
April of 1883 of just the one murder cuz
like I said you know they couldn't
necessarily prove the other ones but
since Israel Swan looked like he had
struggled and there were signs but on
the body so they convicted him of that
murder now I love this even though it's
not true but for some reason whenever
you see this story retold because a lot
of like legends like urban legend and
stuff like that is like you know risen
up about this story the story goes that
when the judge like pronounced him
guilty that he said this is so [ __ ]
great that he said stand up you
voracious man-eatin son of a [ __ ] and
receive your sentence but in him when
you came to Hinsdale
there was seven Democrats but you yeah
eight five of them god damn you i
sentence you to be hanged by the neck
until you're dead dead dead as a warning
against reducing the Democratic
population of this county Packer you
Republican cannibal I would sentence you
to hell but the statutes forbid it
mmm-hmm that was what the legend said
that he said not sure though not exactly
um he might have said something like
that they said the court documents said
that the judge said close your ears to
the blandishments of hope listen not to
the flattering promises of life but
prepare for the dread certainty of death
now he thought that the judge apparently
thought that Packer had just killed him
to rob him and that just ended up eating
them just for survival purposes and that
he maybe had intended to do that the
entire time so yeah so he was sentenced
to hang however that didn't end up
happening even though he was supposed to
hang ended up he was in jail for two
years and then he got the right to a new
trial because what an impact it was like
this legal loophole type of thing they
determined they're like well he can't be
tried for a murder in 1883 for a crime
he committed in 1874 because at the time
the crime was committed
Colorado wasn't a state yet right so
there wasn't so it's not like you know
it was within jurisdiction right so it
was like out of jurisdiction and then
there was also some sources too that
said oh well maybe he was on Indian land
when it happened which would have been
like not federal yeah it would have been
like a federal crime instead so there
was like this big [ __ ] technical
brouhaha so they had to give him a
second trial for the same thing now the
second trial they actually can they
actually came up and charged him with
all five murders not just one yeah now
they're bright not more Nick & Schuster
all's I know what yeah but still did it
yeah they but they actually like reduced
the sentence to voluntary
water instead of murder which kind of
fits more the situation I'm thinking of
what he thinks it's a life or death yeah
yeah okay so he actually did get
convicted of all five voluntary
manslaughter and you want to call it
that he was only sentenced to 40 years
although at this point you know he's in
his 40s or 50s how much had he served at
this point five six two years two years
so I think it was two years forty David
forty that's still a death sentence back
in the day that's what I mean he was
already I believe he was already in his
40s or morningside the conditions in
those prisons you were lucky to make a
[ __ ] yeah and you're [ __ ] yeah yeah
so so he gets sent to prison now in 1897
he wrote a letter to the Denver Rocky
Mountain News with yet another version
look what had happened this dude is just
he can't [ __ ] stop himself okay well
he's gonna lose I doubt so this is his
latest version he says that even before
cuz you know if you'll remember like
there was initially there was a party of
21 people and they had travel and then
they went to the Ute camp and then it
was only the six of them that traveled
because most of them stayed at the you
camp so he said even before they got to
the youth camp the 21 group the 21 man
group were already in a bad way because
they hadn't brought enough supplies and
their planning had been [ __ ] up and
the weather had been bad and whatever so
they said they'd even before they got to
the Ute camp they were already kind of
[ __ ] they were eating the horse feed
and all this other kind of [ __ ] so they
get to the you camp chief or a tells
them hey look the mountains are
impassable he shouldn't go and then he
said there was this guy named Luxan
Heiser and four other guys and they
actually went on an expedition out
before Alfred Packers expedition now
this is the first time as far as I know
that he's ever mentioned that there was
a group of five that went out before
them you know what I'm saying so this is
a whole other like new yarn it's a new
wrinkle yeah
now he said well the chief said that it
was only 40 miles even though it was 80
miles
so then this first group said they also
ran out of supplies and then they did
like the hold we're gonna draw straws to
see who we're gonna eat you know what I
mean which kind of suck is the Donner
Party that is sound right already but
but yeah so then he says that the first
group they saw a coyote and so nobody
got killed and then they found a cow and
they ate that as well and then they
found the guy that liked the farmer or
whoever the rancher that owned the cow
and they went back to that guy's camp
and they got food and everything and
they so then eventually they kind of
like you know ate and stuff but then
they kept going and then they just got
like starved and tired again and then
Packer says yeah we are party left about
a week after his party left but we took
a different trail and now he says the
provisions lasted nine days was it ten
days was seven days was it four days we
don't know he says nine days this time
he says three days after the food ran
out they started they ate their cooked
and ate their shoes and wrapped their
feet up in blanket and I believe me yeah
see he says this so he's like so it was
heavy snow it was like burying the trail
they didn't really know where they were
he said again that Wilson bell-like
started freaking out from starvation and
that he started acting like a crazy
person everybody else was afraid of him
so then they go down to the lake Fork of
the gunnison river and made a camp there
and he said the next morning he went out
to scout and look like for a rancher
like an outpost or somewhere they could
go and again he said when he came back
to the camp Bell was there by himself
and Bell came at him and he yet ended up
having to shoot him in self-defense and
then he realized that all the other guys
were already dead so he this time he's
saying that Bell killed all of them
while he was gone and then Bell turned
on him when he came back and he had to
kill him so he so he's like taking less
and less responsibility like with every
[ __ ] iteration of this tale he's
going crazy in prison he's full of [ __ ]
yeah so his quote was can you imagine my
situation
it's like it's imagination all right my
companions dead and I left alone
surrounded by the midnight horrors of
starvation as well as those of utter
isolation no poor Alfred Packers that
dude ate all those that shift victim
well yeah and so he said that well since
bail had already like cut some flesh off
of Miller just like he said in the
second and third iterations of the story
he's like he saw that he did that but he
didn't need it because he's such a good
guy right he's like he's like no I'm not
gonna eat that I'm too good a person and
said he just like he buried like all his
friends you know who are already dead
yeah it's like I said each iteration of
the story he's getting like more and
more if you're starving if somebody
offers you the meat you do it you eat it
yeah he's just not gonna think about
especially it's cold you're suffering oh
yeah yeah you're dying you're not
yelling death yeah yeah yeah and then he
said so then he said well at this time
because of the isolation and I was
hungry everything like that so then my
mind failed me oh yeah and I woke up the
next morning and he's like and I felt
really and I ate some of the food but it
made me feel really sick and then later
he's like I can't even remember if I
really ate it or not which like I said
it's just he's just like [ __ ] making
himself look better with every version
of this story it's all area the only
thing he could have done after this is
to [ __ ] come up with another
statement saying he wasn't even there
that probably would have been today
I wouldn't on that I wasn't there I just
went off I didn't went over there and I
went to this other outpost I was just I
watched him go
I was waiting there and then he came in
then it came back and when they came
back they were dead hey you know yeah
that that was the ideal like had he done
another version of it that would have
been an X version because that seems
like the next logical thing that he's
just like he didn't even go hey come on
said we were all dying you know two of
them were at death's door they weren't
going anywhere and the other ones [ __ ]
they were [ __ ] crazy
so we ate these two weak ones and then
the other two died and I eat them yeah
and then I took everything he was frozen
I mean the finger privative in like ass
oh yeah I mean look what happened with
the Donner Party it's like when like
everybody I mean the thing about the
Donner Party though is that there were
so many more of them so they had like
you know a corroborating story so they
all pretty much knew what happened
because everybody's stories lined up
their situation was a lot different
because obviously nobody really wanted
to do that [ __ ] and it's like they went
through everything before they got to
that and we're gonna get to that in a
minute though yeah so you know what I'm
saying but this guy it just seems like
oh and you're gonna love this not only
did he say did he now say oh I got back
to the camp and Belle had already killed
them all and then he came at me so I had
to kill him in self-defense
yeah he also said that his escape from
jail yeah the sheriff let me go because
he felt sorry you know why they you know
that jail I didn't escape Neji they let
me they let me out
cuz he felt so bad at like my horrible
situation it's like so you guys should
too and like then he would go like oh
you know that when I said they let me
out that wasn't even me in jail they
actually arrested the wrong dude I just
looked like that yeah I don't like me
grizzled old props I wish we all looked
the same
I was outside a peanut barn Jason I saw
him Ronen us as well I guess it's time
for me to like I need escape from jail
they had the wrong man getting funnier
funnier like every single I like less
and less [ __ ] it wasn't me yeah just
[ __ ] fighting so so yeah so he gets
he actually um got put back in prison
obviously he's so he's in prison the
whole time he served 16 years in prison
and what after he was in prison for 16
years he made a petition for parole the
parole was denied however there was a
reporter at the Denver Post one of the
very early female reporters name is
Polly Prai and she got very interested
in his case believing him to be innocent
she didn't she didn't say that she
thought he was innocent of eating the
people she thought that he ate the
people but she thought that it was like
self-defense or it was like desperation
measure she
did he like killed them on purpose even
though I'm pretty sure that he totally
does yeah I think he killed him yeah I
hate him
yeah so she started a campaign to get
him released and she got the governor in
on it now he made another petition for
parole in 1901 and on that he was
actually granted at this time because he
was in like really really poor health um
he had Bright's disease which nowadays
they would call like nephritis it's like
an acute kidney disorder like you know
what I mean like leads to kidney failure
so since he was in such shitty health
they decided well I guess we'll like let
him walk around free for cuz he probably
won't last much longer so they did give
him parole in 1901 and he was able to I
mean he was able to like persuade like
some people to his cause that he
actually hadn't you know that he
actually hadn't murdered anyone that it
was either self-defense or he had just
done it by that time whatever by that
time it was a long time ago and he was
probably like a relic from the past in
terms of you know legendary well yeah
they're gonna be [ __ ] people that are
gonna like yeah he was innocent yeah I
mean II probably because I think there
were some people that maybe weren't even
alive or were just look at it it's like
when the [ __ ] really happens so they
didn't really know I really know yeah
he's just like I figure from the Old
West cuz talking about 1901 already yeah
the Old West was [ __ ] kind of gone by
that by that right so he would have been
just kind of like something from the
past that you could trip out on you know
that's probably what they did they were
just gonna let him go
ya know small West [ __ ] well and also to
like guys from the Denver the owners of
the Denver Post they petitioned for his
release not because they thought he was
innocent but because they wanted him to
be a sideshow freak yeah and the sells
flute oh so it goes on well it's exactly
what I said yeah because that's what the
Wild West
I'm gonna tell the cannibalism stories
because everyone yeah that's the Old
West by the 1900's was something from a
show like Wild Bill's [ __ ] Wild West
Show and all that you know I mean where
they're reenacting Indian
battles with real Indians yeah and you
know and Kenyan [ __ ] soldiers and
[ __ ] that's what it was so he was an
oddity
they wanted him to come out [ __ ] tell
oh yes which you know probably stories
from a bygone era yeah so they actually
did let him out on parole and he went he
moved to Denver and like works there at
the newspaper like I guess he was some
kind of guard or so they didn't put him
in the circus but he did work there he
didn't like Denver it was too big a city
for him he was more like a frontier type
of guy so he ended up moving to Deer
Creek Canyon in Jefferson County
Colorado he didn't live too much longer
though
he managed a couple of Mines and he
would kind of go around telling stories
about you know the frontier and about
the cannibalism and yet have survived
and yeah it's weird because like a lot
of people back then said he seemed like
a nice little dude he's just like this
grizzled old prospectors it back in my
day we just like wound we had a boy was
a long well a long time had passed he
thought I mean so he probably he was
probably never get snot horrific when
you have that much like that's what
happened
look look back at [ __ ] I did and I was
14 you know I mean it seems like
somebody else did it
yeah you know I mean fact and when you
think about it not a single cell in my
body from when I was 14 it still exists
is replaced by another cell yes is that
you or is that somebody yeah like always
kind of like I always think about stuff
like that I'm like I don't even have the
same yeah you've been completely
replaced you've been completely replaced
by that times I just have it yourself
yeah I only have kind of like a vague
memories of it yes remember everything I
don't really so was that you I don't
know it's really weird to think I can't
bring another you in the same place many
times over so in late to 1906 a state
game warden found Alfred Packer
unconscious within a mile from his home
apparently you've gone for a walk and
appeared that he had a stroke or he had
some kind of thing so he ended up did
of a stroke in April of 1907 before he
died he'd actually written to the
governor to request a full pardon
however this was not granted
yeah like [ __ ] you they're like no you
people but yeah so he did have a grave
it's still there it was actually paid
for by the government because he'd been
in the military so there's like a little
Alfred it has like his military rank and
everything like that um and apparently
there's like little pilgrimages and [ __ ]
to his great to his grave like I said
they did cannibal the musical is based
on him there's like folk songs yeah
based on him [ __ ] like that oh I should
mention too this is interesting and this
is what I was talking about when I was
talking about uh yet finding the bodies
all together and [ __ ] like that so in
1989 there's this law professor from
George Washington University named James
II stars and he's always been interested
in the Alfred Packer case and because no
one was entirely sure anymore because it
had been such a long time like where the
five prospectors were buried because
presumably they were left where they
found them I don't think they moved them
or anything so he wanted to know if they
were still there so so they go to the
place that's now called a dead man's
Gulch which is what they called it where
they found the bodies even though no one
was really sure there was like you know
there was a monument erected there but
no one was entirely sure if the bodies
were still there or not so he wanted to
they did like the ground-penetrating
radar and all that kind of stuff and
then he got like some our key
archaeology students he's like we're
gonna go dig there and see if we can
find the bodies so July 1989 they get
all the diggers out there and [ __ ] like
that and they didn't have to like dig
very deep and they found all five with
bodies damn like right there and they're
just like and there's I have a picture
of it and they're all just like laying
like right next to each other like super
close together there's like oh they're
all like love was there side by side
yeah I mean they didn't have any flesh
Andrew skeleton no that's right there's
five skeletons but they were like right
next to each other and so I'm presuming
that the you know because when they went
and found in the search party like back
in the 1800s I don't think they moved
them I think they just buried them were
they wear them up yeah um so that's so
that's where they were like dead man's
Gulch they're like yep
that's where we put the monument
that's when able to find out any more
about how they died not a lot they said
um because they're like so they didn't
really find any wounds it's like that
one of the bones looked like it had a
hole in it that could have been a bullet
hole but they're like they couldn't
really determine if it was a bullet hole
or not because it's like it might have
been like a [ __ ] yeah animal bite it
could have been like lots of different
things so you know three of the bodies
did have blunt force trauma blows to the
back of the head and had cuts on the
arms and hands which they said were
probably defensive winds so that was two
or three people that had fought back not
just one also they found some nicks on
the bones that they presumed were from
cutting on me cutting the meat off
defleshing them so these people
presumably they came to the conclusion
there like even though we can't be
entirely sure but we're pretty sure that
this guy just killed all of them in cold
blood
yeah that ate them so they did Ribery
them they like put them all in boxes and
everything like and put them back in the
same if they had like a big funeral and
everything moral of the story is boys
should have told a better lie yeah not a
not a super good liar no from the
beginning Lee even back in the 1800s
when everyone was kind of a dummy and
didn't know anything but it's like even
then like he comes back with this yarn
and everyone's just like no no I think I
think that it caught me out it told ya I
ate him I eat a mom say we were all had
to yeah had to - had to to survive we're
all at the edge of death none of us were
getting out of there and I said [ __ ]
so I just rolled over and [ __ ]
crashed
contem in the back of the head [ __ ]
2/3 of them were about dead anyway and
there was no way we were making it out
of there I mean [ __ ] I hate them all you
needed it for the string you would have
to if you were in that takes a
wheelchair you could even I mean you
probably would have got more lenient
with the forensic you know situation as
it was back then you could probably even
just say that they had died of
starvation or or of exposure and you
just eaten them yeah you wouldn't even
have to nestle might have been close to
the truth I mean you could say that you
killed one of them in self-defense cuz
he was coming at you or whatever but
it's like you could probably have gotten
away with saying oh you know he was
dropping dead chances of them believe in
you out of that situation are very
[ __ ] slim yeah you could have said
two of them were already dead and the
other ones were dying so yeah it just
seemed like every time he told the story
he was taking less and less
responsibility it's like oh well I
wasn't there for one of them I wasn't
there for two of them and then it
suddenly I came back and they were all
dead
you think gachi you're gonna [ __ ] you're
good look at that cat look at this right
why do you want to show everybody your
booty yeah it wouldn't be a show with
Vishu without some kid sticking her wife
Lydia crazy sit down be good girl there
you go oh so you get to your little ears
yeah in the corner what yeah she had a
she was plain old that's what he debts I
mean you're gonna [ __ ] get caught
you're gonna do Tom you better [ __ ]
put yourself in it yeah yeah because
it's right no one's gonna buy I was
gonna buy this shoe I wasn't I wasn't
there everything yeah no yeah it's not I
said I hate every one of them had to to
live yeah they looked you probably would
instead of getting that 20 22 years
where they say 20 something years 30
years for 40 years prior to only giving
you 10 if you said no I [ __ ] ate him
yeah well yeah cuz you know hey I'm
gonna had to live if you could have like
like I said if you'd have given him some
mitigating circumstance like hey I was
starving and hey I didn't do it none of
us would be a lot like little chicken
legs Bobby that was you know how ago I
was insane with hunt hunger I was the
strongest one and [ __ ] they were all
gonna die anyway so [ __ ] you know I
mean I did what I had to do to live to
them are already dead the other two at
death's door see that sounds like a much
like 1/8 of a bull and I ate him and I
carried it all with me to [ __ ]
survive to come back Jeremiah Johnson
style and any [ __ ] you know I mean on
the way back I had to fight off a bear
fight off a whole [ __ ] Indian tribe
and a Bigfoot yeah got me
to an indian bride on the way back and
then that [ __ ] divorced me i'm still
paying [ __ ] alimony for that [ __ ]
baby then yeah we're there bid and then
they'd been son I got yeah sounds sounds
likely I remember I mean sounds like a
median girls boy yeah what happened
that's you should have just straight up
bro that [ __ ] the heap he pushed out
yeah I just
Irina why he thought anyway I really
think he killed the other dudes of room
in reality I think he killed the dudes
cuz he was posted out he's that well
yeah like I said night yeah I want to go
home I think I mean I want to go home
like I said the [ __ ] that I was reading
about the Donner Party they survived a
thousand times worse and for much longer
than this little piddling expert here I
think he was puss and half of them lived
yeah I think he was pushing out and he
wanted to bail out yeah he's just like
this sucks and he thought it was a lot
worse than it was and he [ __ ] killed
those dudes and ate him and got out of
there yeah they're still robably
unnecessarily that's cut yeah yeah
that's what I'm assuming Leslie I don't
think that he would have had to I'm not
saying they all would have made it and
I'm just saying I don't think the
situation was as dire as because he had
that [ __ ] element in him he it behooves
him to lie he couldn't go roll with it
yeah I mean so he had to come up with a
lie and I didn't even see anything I was
there and I saw this big hairy man
[ __ ] big hairy man it looked like a
wild man look like I don't know what I
saw its eyes and it vanished he went off
to the other dimension you went off to
the other man and also the leave
footprints also those drugs you found in
my pocket says we're not mine a friend
put those in there I even it doesn't
even my panties I don't even know where
they should be even it [ __ ] I'm [ __ ]
Bigfoot like that have been really fun
all right let's get this Donner Party
yeah we got to talk about the time for
the dawn up I'm tired of talking us bout
to say
we got him sorted out but yeah I know
what I'm dealing with this dude this
story so depressing it just seemed like
this is just a you know an example of an
eye the same nature hates you just like
nature is indifferent toward you nature
hates you and oh and also it's like one
bad decision like you don't even know
it's a bad decision at the time but it's
just like compounds and snowballs into
this horrific just giant [ __ ] of
awfulness mmm I mean just the worst [ __ ]
happened they had like the most rotten
[ __ ] luck I mean yeah they made like
one or two dumb decisions or at least a
couple of them did but it just seemed
like this one tiny little dumb decision
like led to like all this [ __ ]
horrible yojo [ __ ] happening to that one
it shows the wrong route from what I
remember that was the main problem yeah
it's you know shortcut yeah which wasn't
actually right but you know they didn't
know that and that was kind of like this
out of thing so this happened earlier
than our Alfred Packer case this
happened in 1846 now most people have
heard of the Donner Party and I think if
you asked most people is just like
survey people in the street you asking
about the Donner Party they'll say like
what Danny Torrance said mm-hmm they ate
each other up which to an extent that's
true but there's more to it than that
there's a lot more to it than that
like I said the I think the book that I
was trying to think of earlier that they
were talking about about last on last
podcast in the left is called the
indifferent stars above and it goes like
really really into like just kind of the
whole frontier experience like going out
west in general but the Donner Party in
particular and it goes like really into
like all the show because they have like
a lot of their letters and stuff because
I think what I didn't realize I learned
about the Donner Party in school but I
had forgotten a lot about it what I
didn't realize was about half of them
lived you know they didn't all die
well actually what had happened was
pretty well recorded by the Civil it was
there was like everybody exactly what
happens like pretty much from day to day
even the name
the people who are standing around the
fire that fell not to fire overall fire
out on with certain nights and [ __ ] like
that bunch of weird should it happen yes
very well documented I read a book about
it back in the eighth grade Becka
Southern California Military Academy
coming up it tripped me out the [ __ ]
that they were doing I don't remember
all the details but remember the janitor
of generalities you had a lot of people
that weren't really well they were what
you call greenhorns they weren't really
used to being out in the field most of
them they were the kind of people that
would really be in a city they were kind
of more used to taking trains but they
had to go somewhere in a wagon they got
caught up in a [ __ ] bad winter up in
the [ __ ] went up in the up in the
mountains and made it but maybe they
made poor decisions once they were up
there they should have just kept going
or walking or walking down the mountains
but they decided to wait and that was
part of the problem you can't wait well
like I said there was a lot of things
that went wrong and it wasn't always
entirely their fault because they were
going on advice from people that they
thought they thought about that they
didn't ended up killing a bunch of them
which is really sad so this happened in
April of 1846 so there were nine covered
wagons leaving Springfield Illinois now
this is a 2,500 mile journey out to
California now even though the party
gets called the Donner Party there was a
whole bunch of families and the donners
were one of the families that were on
there but they weren't even like the
ones in charge at least in the beginning
the head of the you know wagon train at
the beginning was it got was a guy
called James Reid now he was a
businessman from Illinois and he had
been wanting to go out to California
also his wife had like problems with
migraines and stuff and he thought like
the climate out there would be better
for her so he ended up reading this book
which was very very popular at the time
it was called the immigrants guide to
Oregon and California now at this point
in the 1840s a lot of people that were
going out west had ended up emigrating
to Oregon because it was much easier to
get to like you didn't have to go
through like all these like [ __ ]
and inconvenient mountain ranges and
stuff like there were easier trails up
there so a lot of the settlers had like
settled in Oregon but eventually they
started like going into California even
though at the time it was much harder to
get into Andres not to go in those
mountains because the Great Plains
Indians were still around at that time
yeah and they were kind of like the damn
Pirates of the plains you didn't want to
get captured by them Plains Indians were
badasses well and they were always kind
of like looking at all these like and
they're like hey look at these white
people that don't know they're going
they have a bunch of cool [ __ ] we could
probably take yeah and you know they
were a masculine bunch but all accounts
strong and good-looking people very
[ __ ] very [ __ ] intelligent well
they had been living well here for
thousands of years so they were like
they knew the terrain they knew a lot of
this [ __ ] about the superior white man
coming over here to the to the [ __ ]
West and dominating Indians with guns is
[ __ ] pure Hollywood that's not exactly
what has asked kicked most of the time
it was mostly disease and interbreeding
really that well they just kind of like
blundered onto this continent and they
weren't used to the terrain they weren't
used to the climate in in some areas you
know obviously it was much easier to
settle like the Northeast and stuff
because it was a very similar climate to
Europe and that's what they were used to
but when they started going out west
they didn't have any experience with
anything like that right nothing that
pisses me off is that a lot of these
modern educate Mountain none of these
modern so-called educated people always
talking about racism you know about how
racist the white man was against the
[ __ ] Indians that's all [ __ ] there
the canoe the writings of the time
especially going back to the sixteen and
seventeen hundred's is nothing but just
damn [ __ ] I'm a white boys man crush
on how [ __ ] great the Indians were
you got to go read back how you got to
read the old literature okay
not even this new [ __ ] but then the
Indians were far ahead of the white man
but like I said they'd been living here
they had been living here for thousands
of years they had their own technologies
they were very intelligent and they had
a lot of physical prowess all right they
whipped the white man's ass for hundreds
and hundreds of years down here it was
until the Industrial Revolution really
that the Indian cultures slowly were
absorbed and we're dead and basically
you know disappeared that's a that's a
modern phenomenon back in this day the
Indian ran the [ __ ] game here wasn't
until [ __ ] trains and telegraph but
like I said particularly out west
because that was just like a completely
what and and a lot of the West back then
was also still owned by Mexico I mean
we're out of a large part of Canada or
California rather a text box not Mexico
yeah right
so yes so this book the emigrants could
guide to Oregon and California had been
written by this fella named Lansford W
Hastings now one of the big things don't
I'm not saying like this entire book was
[ __ ] because there was like some
good advice in there like hey if you're
going out west
you can't leave any later than I believe
it was May first because then you're
gonna end up in the middle of the
mountains in the winter and it's like
you don't want to do that because you
know how long it takes to get through
there which was good advice however one
of the most famous and also most
unfortunate pieces of advice in there
was he had come up with a supposedly new
route to California that supposed that
was supposed to be a shortcut supposed
to cut 3352 400 miles off your journey
going to California and it was supposed
to be like an easy trip now what a lot
of people that read this book is this is
a very popular book at the time like a
lot of people that were going out west
were reading this [ __ ] and believed in
it
problems okay there's two problems first
problem was that what they didn't know
was that Lanford lens for w hastings had
ulterior motives for getting people out
to california because he had like this
deal with a land of L
per type you know dude like your company
out there and they said we'll give you X
amount of lots out here in California if
you can bring like a bunch of settlers
here to buy plots of land you know bring
X amount of settlers here so he's
writing a book making California seem
like it's this big paradise everybody
has to come here and all this other kind
of [ __ ] second problem was that his
supposed shortcut the route that he
liked touted very much in this book he'd
never done it like in person he just
looked at a map and was like yeah that
looks like that would be easier yeah dad
doesn't work out no what are they cuz
the map is not the terrain and that what
they say throughout history many men
have looked at the map and saying oh
that should be no problem wait it off
Hitler being one of them looking at the
map of the Soviet Union Soviet Union oh
there would be no problem it's only this
big was like it was a bit cold yes we'll
just move our guys here it'll be okay
well you know it's very easy to like
move [ __ ] around there risk board John
the risk board and that was seemed like
the same situation this it's like he
apparently looked at a map and thought
that he saw a route that looked easy on
paper and he wrote in his book that
thousands and thousands of people were
reading and buying into him going yeah
sounds legit yeah not legit 350 to 400
miles off the journey we go to
California this big paradise it'll be
super easy throughout history many the
men that drew the maps weren't there
it's kind of like that's some funny [ __ ]
that's what I mean it's like yeah almost
all this mathematical in there I don't
know you ever been there you haven't
seen it and that's like kind of what
happened with him yeah he did kind of
like man up later and we'll get into
that a little bit later on like he did
man up later and go oh maybe I should
like run this route and see if it
actually works or not but that by that
time it was like too late to say the
people in the Donner
party who had already like followed this
[ __ ] advice so James Reid who like I
said he was the one that kind of
instigated the whole diner which is why
sometimes they actually call it the
Donner
Reid party not the Donna Reed party
that's a totally different kind of party
which may be it I don't know if it's
quite as horrific I'm sure that didn't
know Donna Reed when she was alive
but yeah so James Reid he finds him and
his family they find like a whole bunch
of other families that want to go out to
California so he's like okay well we'll
do like a wagon train out there we'll
all go together so they have the Donner
family the graves family the brains the
Murphy's the Edie's the mccutchins the
Casa Berg's
and the wulfing arrggh wool fingers
Wolf's layers they also had seven
Teamsters which was like the guy that
drove the teams of animals a bunch of
single guys so this initial group that
was going on the journey was 32 men
women and children in nine wagons as I
said so James and Margaret Reid they had
four kids they were also taking
Margaret's 70 year old mother Sarah Keys
who had the imagination well she had
consumption anima t70 yeah well the
reason that she wanted to go was because
she didn't think that she would live
long enough to see the family again
right so she said well you might as well
as she she's right on a trip yeah well
she did but um spoiler alert but she she
just wanted to be with them you know I
mean cuz she was afraid that she would
die without seeing them again what she
you can understand that so she just like
I'll probably die in the trail but at
least I want to be with you guys like
when it happens so they did take her
along now the thing about it James Reid
by all accounts was a very imperious
arrogant sort of dude he was the one
that had put the you know initial party
together and he was just kind of like my
way or the highway tip a guy it seems
like that's kind of how he comes across
like in a lot of the [ __ ] also his wagon
when you're thinking like a little wagon
like Little House on the Prairie like a
little bitty wagon was like nothing in
there no man
stood had the whole [ __ ] kitted out
there was a two-story wagon
he had like a [ __ ] iron stove in
there like a buildin had like the seats
had like spring cushions in them have
like bunks in there it was like a
[ __ ] Winnebago on the [ __ ] okay like
back in the back in the 1800s Winnebago
Sal it was like that so it was like
super fancy
so all these wagons were brand new was
nine of them initially now they assumed
from the outset that the journey was
going to take four months okay which you
know that was about how long it would
take like on the more you know the more
mapped trail that like people had
actually taken and like had worked out
and stuff so they're assuming like four
months so they packed for four months
worth of [ __ ] so they go to the first
place they go is Independence Missouri
which was where you usually went that
was kind of like your bit last big
outpost before you went on like the
Oregon Trail at the California trails um
so okay so at this point like I said the
the donners were also on here this was
George Donner and Jacob Donner they were
brothers and both of their families were
on here George Donner was 62 now this
was his fifth or sixth migration so he
had done this before
like he wasn't a total greenhorn yeah or
Tenderfoot or whatever the hell they
call it he had done this several times
before but he had been living in
Illinois for quite a while with his
brother they said well this will be the
last one we're just gonna go out to
California would be paradise and stuff
like that unfortunately it's funny we
talk about places like Illinois and
these are boring places today the back
in this era this was you're talking
about like something on the map of the
[ __ ] Mad Max video game yeah you know
talking about these were wild [ __ ]
places back then in the United States
yeah and you're not talking about the
United States as you know it many of
these places weren't really States some
of the world territories yeah they none
of the ones out west where's the other
one
yeah and really they were owned by you
know the tribe tribe it was Indian
Territory interpret or Mexico and these
yeah and these Indians man were like
something straight out of [ __ ] fury
road and you know
I'm talking about some Hollywood
[ __ ] Indians he's dudes were [ __ ]
badasses and were the samurai of the
[ __ ] of America and guns didn't
really help you against them [ __ ] you
know to most of history the bow get the
guns back then guns back then we're
single-shot [ __ ] yeah well then you have
to like sit there and put the liquor
[ __ ] yeah and during that time is
[ __ ] physical prowess [ __ ]
just came up there and just beat you to
death with a damn war club or a bow as
fired a lot more a lot faster and it was
silent then say a muzzleloading
matchlock or flintlock guns didn't help
you
guns were a white boy thing yeah on the
battlefield the gun was the weakest
worst weapon for a long time until the
eighteen hundreds well until they
actually made it was no they had a
repeating centerfire cartridges you know
I mean like the lever action carbine
that's really when you had the single
shot to was okay but during this era you
know 1840s gods really work well you get
one shot off they one shot accurate and
then it would take like how long did it
take like at least a minute or two you
know it depends on what it was depending
on what's that began it was depending on
what it was you know a muzzle loader you
had to [ __ ] drop get it get a
cartridge which is a [ __ ] tube a tube
of wax paper with powder and a bullet
alright and what you did is is you
[ __ ] mash the bullet in the muzzle
okay excuse me you [ __ ] broke the end
of it and you [ __ ] dropped all the
powder in there down into the barrel and
you took that piece of paper
alright you mash that up against the
mouth and put the [ __ ] bullet in the
thing and then you used a little hammer
to knock the bullet into the muzzle and
then a rod to push it down to the bottom
and then you either had a matchlock on
the bottom but you had to [ __ ] put
some powder on or you put the percussion
cap on there it's you know it I mean
after you [ __ ] the hammer back who fired
it took a while I mean I feel like even
if you got good at it that would take at
least a minute
yeah right 30 seconds maybe I mean I you
know I think I remember seeing I saw
like some show or something like that
were
guy was like who was good at it yeah was
showing how long it took I think it took
him like between 30 and 45 seconds and
he was like super fast like he had done
a muzzleloading weapon was only good in
a skirmish line which is a huge
formation of hundreds of men the guys in
the back are reloading the guys up front
are shooting right and there they had
like a rotation in the rotation you
don't have to do it but that was only in
European armies out in European
battlefield so that's not the [ __ ]
what you're talking about in the Old
West yeah you don't have enough guys
with you to do that all right
they carried those things because they
were good for hunting yeah they weren't
that good for defense unless you had a
bunch of them some guys would carry a
rifle and maybe two pistols in it so you
have three shots yeah you know now later
on you had revolvers okay that were
percussion cap all right that had five
to six shots each you know and then a
car being whatever rifle would have one
so a lot of times you see them with like
two revolvers in her and a rifle but but
all of that [ __ ] was [ __ ] kind of
like not practical because if it rained
all the powder got wet yeah and you were
kind of raised if you if you fired that
[ __ ] off at night the chances you've
been able to reloaded at night are
pretty slim cuz there's no light
yeah yeah you can so Indians knew all
this [ __ ] too then the Indians had guns
they knew about them they didn't like
them Indians didn't like guns for their
situation like that shocking [ __ ]
was impractical impractical it was
[ __ ] and they knew the weaknesses of
them it wasn't until metallic case
cartridges that Indians started to adopt
rifles and they really went went for it
later on and like you know in the later
part of the 1800s when you had [ __ ]
lever action repeating carbines that you
could load 14 12 to 14 rounds and I'm
you know in a tubular magazine and work
the damn you know the lever action and
yeah that was the ak-47 of its time they
loved those all right and they had lots
of those and they were the most
expensive ones and in the later part of
the tribal era the Indians
had repeating carbines alright in a time
when the US Army didn't they had
single-shot rifles so actually most of
the time the Indians were better armed
than the US Army yeah
because those were expensive which is
funny to think about yeah yeah those
were expensive you know but people
forget India's had money Indians were
people yeah these were not [ __ ] wild
animals [ __ ] people yeah okay they
[ __ ] could make money and trade and
they lived a good lifestyle and they
could afford the best weapons that were
out there and they were fighting for
their culture which is a mobile culture
which anyone would do anybody would but
you know the advent of Telegraph's and
trains really [ __ ] change the scene
and by the time automobiles first
appeared that was it you just you're
just not gonna be able to traipse
through people's [ __ ] property yeah
you know man [ __ ] there with
everything aterna to kit farmland by
that time and you just Indians got jobs
and like I said buddy you know their
population had been depleted their
bodies and [ __ ] like that so yeah they
weren't like as it was mid numerous as
they and we were talking about a 300
year period yeah of interbreeding with
white people all right you could say
Mexicans were Indians there was another
kind of India and they were interfering
with Spaniards Spaniards but
interbreeding with [ __ ] Europeans
disease getting jobs changing of
lifestyles it's just over time it just
you know I mean yeah I mean it took a
long time but go out right now and try
to form a tribe and run around and hunt
Buffalo and kill people's [ __ ] you
know and eat those and go steal [ __ ] and
see how long that [ __ ] laughs it ain't
gonna last you know the Industrial Age
ended that era yeah that's what got him
now you can say well they've moved a lot
of him onto reservations that was
actually kind of like the last remnants
they had ancestors before them that had
blended in with white people too because
not all not all Indians stayed in the
tribes and not all white people stayed
with white people because they know this
for a fact yeah we talked about this a
lot I'm like the
Roanoke show yes and here we live in an
area that is this used to be Seminole
territory yes the Seminoles were mostly
Irish well and a lot of [ __ ] around here
is like has Indian it's a year the
Indian names in Spanish the Indian
lifestyle back in the day was better
than the white man's lifestyle was freer
more naturalistic it didn't have so many
rules it was more healthy you didn't
have to live in a [ __ ] city fresh
water fresh meat the Seminoles were at
least half Irish and they had Black
Seminoles yeah and you had Indians so
you could join a tribe a lot of people
did it and there was these [ __ ] old
stories about Indians capturing the
white women and so they'd go in there
and take the white women away from the
Indians and then in the morning they
wake up the white women were gone
because they went back to the Indians
they're like it's better yeah people
[ __ ] make these weird of some shion's
people joined Indian tribes back in
those days it was a good lifestyle I
told you before I probably totally would
have done I would have rather done that
yeah
sixteen seventeen hundred s if you gave
me a choice between being a white man or
an Indian I would said nah I would
rather be a Lakota well particularly in
you know if you were originally from
Europe and you were used to that
lifestyle and like moved here into it
into a climate and a terrain that was
unfamiliar to you yeah it seems like you
would want to throw your lot in with
people that actually knew like had lived
there and knew what was going on yeah
and had adapted to that particular and
there were and a lot of the things you
grew up with like the restrictions that
were placed upon you because as a
society and religion would vanish yeah
it didn't matter and pretty much by all
accounts the Lakota was where it was
really where was that they were strong
very intelligent they were well-equipped
well-dressed they had their own songs
their own cultures they traveled a lot
they were Raiders but they admired
strength and they admired beauty and
their [ __ ] health was good they did
things that by today's standards would
be not acceptable but it was kind of
like life on the high seas you know I
mean the rules were different on
on the high plains yeah you had to
survive a different way sometimes you
had to take things you know but that's
just the way nature is you know the
Lakota were predatory but they also
recognized members of their own tribe
you know I mean they had an allegiance
seasons [ __ ] I get off on that Indian
stuff man and I yeah it's the same way
with the Mexican Indians I don't mean me
and Jaya are always talking about you
know the Aztecs Jaguar magic Jaguar
power you know growing up in South
America in Brazil you know if I could
see in you know Indians and stuff and
Central and South American [ __ ]
cultures you know ancient cultures they
were [ __ ] badasses man they were
[ __ ] way ahead of Europe and mint in
some ways especially you know
architecture it's just lunchtime it's
funny how they didn't really know until
quite recently that you know some of the
cities in Central and South America at
the at the same time as like some of the
biggest cities in Europe
I mean we're comparable yeah in size and
architectural complexity there's this
[ __ ] kind of like thinking that the
Indians were primitive no not at all
they their technology was different but
the situation was different yeah it's a
different climate I mean it's a
different climate it's a deviation that
they had to deal with in general there
was the big difference between the
Indians and say like the Japanese
samurai they're about like the samurai
there's a different lifestyle yeah was
it much difference you know I guess you
could say the samurai were agricultural
most of the Indians were hunter-gatherer
but you know they were still highly
developed well yeah I mean like I said
they had gigantic just different cities
and gigantic settlements and stuff it
was just you know the the climate was
different you know the terrain was
different when when Cortes saw the
original version of Mexico City it
terrified his troops they were it was
huge it was bigger than any city in
Europe yeah and it was painted in bright
colors you know you're not talking about
cheap-ass [ __ ] it was well made and it
was you know it seemed advanced well
even if you just see the ruins nowadays
they're like amazing yeah they're
amazing
look at and they were huge bundles of
[ __ ] heads and decapitated heads and
lots of bodies because they were doing
human sacrifice they were they were
terrified you know I mean because the
religion you know you had to pay back
the blood debt yeah which is man they
were [ __ ] bizarre man but that's you
just got to see Apocalypto that is
absolute that movie is absolutely that's
what it was like but that's the thing
it's like if you if you look interviews
that's why I'm kind of like interested
about people's like religions and
mythologies and stuff like that because
if you look at the you know climate in
which they live you can totally
understand why certain myths arose why
certain why their lifestyle arose the
way it did because it just it happened
very naturally in the way that they yeah
you know what I mean it later very easy
to see how that happened after Cortes
and his Indian allies had deposed the
[ __ ] Aztec after the Aztec rule Spain
sent a bunch bunch of a priest and
friars to analyze what was going on to
learn the language and they wrote a big
old book to sat up in the Vatican for
[ __ ] hundreds of years
unread okay cuz that's how it was back
then they would read a book hey Pope
this is what's going on here in Mexico
is like I'll [ __ ] that just file it I
don't have time time to read that [ __ ]
but if you read that book it's the
Friars are going you know the Aztec
religion it seems [ __ ] satanic and
very brutal all this human sacrifice but
every God that they worship kind of has
a Catholic analogy to it is that this is
us this is a religion very similar to
Catholic ways and that you know and
because of that we were able to convert
them to Catholicism and that's where all
this stuff like macumba comes from I'm
saying if you look at it it's very
awesome
I was just gonna say that like all the
[ __ ] about like Haitian voodoo and other
kind of stuff it's they found it very
easy to like graft Catholicism on
because they're like oh they got it they
got that original good spirits bad suits
Saints it was very simple trying to
appease evil spirits to keep them off of
you and giving off
so it like I said there's only so many
different ways you can imagine right
there's only so many like human brains
are the same everywhere and at all times
so it's like we only go in like an X
amount of directions you know what I
mean it's like it they come out like it
comes out a little weirder like
depending on what your culture is like
dependent yeah you know there's little
differences here and there but when you
really get down to it there are a lot
more similar than there yeah and kind of
like this European snobbery about
technology which kind of [ __ ] even
goes on these some of these some of the
[ __ ] that I've heard about all you know
it college-educated people say the
difference between the technology of the
Europeans and the Indians during the 15
16 17 it wasn't enough to make a real
difference and if anything the Indians
had a technological advantage in some
ways it wasn't until this trains and
Telegraph's and and smokeless powder and
[ __ ] you know the metallic cartridges
that's kind of when European technology
was better over to over took it and
that's Industrial Revolution before that
time really you know the Indians were
doing it the old-fashioned way and that
was the really the better way well and
they had a tactical advantage too but
yes like I said they have lived here for
thousands of years they knew the terrain
in Israel you know so they have like a
lot of advantage it was sad even back in
those days you captured an Indian and
take him and strip him down totally
naked and let him go and [ __ ] he
defied him 30 days later he had
everything he needed yeah his clothes
his weapons because he could make
anything yeah you know well that's what
they did they just like write everything
out of their environment right and
that's why they were trying to avoid him
with this damn path that they were
trying to do you this shortcut that
wasn't a short one is sure it actually
like later on when they tell you is
actually like a hundred fifty miles
longer yeah so yeah so all right so the
the original nine wagon train with the
32 people starts out there's several
families they start out from Illinois
now interestingly on this very same day
that this party started out from
Springfield Illinois
good old Lansford Hastings the guy that
wrote the immigrants guide to Oregon and
California he finally decided hey maybe
I should actually like try out this
quote unquote shortcut that I wrote
about in my book that everybody's read
and like now they're all doing it maybe
I should check and see if that's
actually legit so he did actually to his
credit even though he'd already
published the book and like a bunch of
people had like decided to do it he's
like finally he's like well okay well
I'll do it so he set out the same day to
do the shortcut and see how it worked
out so we'll see how that goes so the
original wagon train reaches
Independence Missouri took about three
weeks to get there and at this point
they resupplied all their stuff now the
next day there was a really bad
thunderstorm but they headed out anyway
a week after that they joined another
large wagon train which was captained by
again in Colonel William Russell now
this was camped on Indian Creek about a
hundred miles west of Independence so
the two of them like meeting up now the
the group was it originally started out
with thirty-two people now it's 87
people okay so like I said Donner Party
I always had the impression even when I
learned about it in school that it was
just like a family or two but no it was
like a whole bunch of families like it
was a [ __ ] ton of people and a [ __ ] ton
of wagons so May 25th this whole train
of like uh you know all these 87 people
there was some flooding at the Big Blue
River which is near present-day
Marysville Kansas now while they were at
this they were waiting outlook for the
floodwaters to to subside old
consumptive 70 year old Sarah Keys died
you know the one they had brought along
so they buried her next to the river now
to get across the river they had to bury
this is the thing about the [ __ ]
Donner Party and this is like back in
the old days you couldn't just like you
brought [ __ ] with you but a lot of the
stuff you had to like build while you
were on cuz like if you had a camp
somewhere like for the winter you had to
like bill
a cabin like you had to cut down trees
and build a cabin it brought tools with
it wherever they yeah they had tools and
like food and [ __ ] like that but it's
like a lot of that kind of stuff like
shelters and stuff you had to build it
like on site see movie called Jeremiah
Johnson John oh yeah same guy who did
Conan the Barbarian and they show I'm
doing this kind of [ __ ] yeah how to
build a cabin or a house without nails
yeah so to get across this flooded river
they actually had to build like little
fairies like to put the wagons on like
to get across the river so they had to
do that so they actually did that
successfully it took about a month like
to get across there now there had been a
guy who was like the captain of the
wagon train at this point his name was
William Russell but at this point he's
like nom out and he quit so they took a
another guy took over named William
Boggs now for the next month it seems
like they didn't really I mean it's
summertime
they didn't really seem to have a lot of
problems you know it seemed to go fairly
smoothly so they get to Fort Laramie
which was their next big stop on June
27th 1846 now this was only a week
behind schedule so they're still doing
fairly well at this point and it like I
said it's still summertime everything's
fine at this point while they're at Fort
Laramie James Reid who was the one that
had put the original Donna Reed party
together he runs into this dude who he
knows from Illinois like an old friend
of his whose name was James climbin now
coincidentally James Klieman had just
gone this new route that Lansford
Hastings had suggested the Hastings
cutoff as they called it at a shortcut
he had just done it and Klieman said yo
it's not a good idea he's like seriously
James don't do it it's like we did it on
foot and it sucked enough on foot you're
not gonna get wagons through there I
would not advise it
okay so here's someone tell and he this
is this dude's friend they knew each
other from Becka Illinois he's been on
it and he's like look we just went
through was like on foot and with
a couple of horses and it sucked really
bad in the summer time you're not
getting wagons through there I wouldn't
go that way
Otto said thank you very much that's
right you would think but [ __ ] it's
called a [ __ ] scalp telling you
giving you the information you [ __ ]
need he's like look there's a big
[ __ ] desert
yeah why it's like [ __ ] lie
right I don't understand he's like I've
been there it sucked okay he's like
seriously don't go that way yeah James
Reid though for whatever reason
like I said everybody thought that he
was like kind of an arrogant douche so I
guess he thought he knew better he's
like hey I read it in this book right
here it was printed yeah they know more
than you and written in this book even
though the guy that wrote the book had
never been there I've been there but
he's like what's in this book and it's
like I think that's the way we should go
so he decided they were gonna go that
way yes so you know this that was their
first believe what are you writing their
first mistakes
now before Reid and the rest of the
party had left Fort Laramie this guy
shows up and he had a letter from
Lansford W Hastings himself the guy that
had written the book now in the letter
Hastings said hey you guys I will meet
all of you at Fort Bridger and I will
personally lead you on my shortcut that
I wrote about in the book the Hastings
cutoff you know so at that point because
that letter came from Hastings himself
the guy that have written the book who I
guess they believed like had been on
this route before and like knew what he
was talking about even though he did not
so a lot of the settlers were like okay
well cool he's gonna meet us and he's
gonna show us the way and it'll all be
fine
so that's how that worked out so what it
what ended up happening so July 19th the
wagon train comes to the little sandy
River which is in Wyoming wasn't Wyoming
then but it's Wyoming now now at this
point there was still like a large part
of the party that were just like I'm
just not we're gonna take the route that
all the other settlers have taken that
we know you know that there's outposts
along it
we know it's been mapped it's like other
people have done it so most of the wagon
train took the safer route because it
was a tested route the minority of the
wagon train which ended up being the
tragic Donner Party as it came to be
known to history took the Hastings
cutoff which had not been tested because
it was supposed to be quicker like I
said even though that's not how it
turned out so it splits off into two you
know contingents now the way the the
group that went off on the Hastings
cutoff they elected George Donner as
their captain and hence it became known
as the Donner Party so they started
going along the southerly route the
safer route was the northerly route that
had been done by like many other
settlers before it was mapped everybody
knew that way but this way was supposed
to be shorter so that's what the way
that they went so they get to Fort
Bridger on July 28th where they were
supposed to meet this Hastings fella
however by the time they got to Fort
Bridger
apparently Hastings had already left but
he did leave a letter there that said
yeah I was here I left with another
group you guys should just catch up with
us now there were a couple of guys there
Jim Bridger and also his partner Luis
Vasquez and they said no no the Hastings
cutoff it's totally legit it's totally
fine you guys are gonna be fine it's
much faster you know it's it's totally
fine
so they again felt like okay about their
decision so like I said you can [ __ ] on
them for making dumb decisions
but you have to think that they were
being given really shitty advice by
people they had every reason to believe
knew what they were talking about yeah
so you can't entirely blame them you
know what I'm saying even though I I
feel like if it was me I probably would
have been like yeah let's go with the
safer route which
a lot of the wagon train did like most
of them went on the the tested route
that had been done like a lot of times
before because they thought that their
odds would probably be better a year on
the side of caution that's what I'm
thinking like especially in this kind of
situation so so they decided see they're
like okay well it's all gonna be fine so
they stay at this at this fort for a
little while like getting wagons fixed
like stocking up and resting and all
this other kind of [ __ ] so July 31st
they leave Fort Bridger and this was now
a group of 74 people and 20 wagons now
for the first week it seemed fine they
were actually making these you know the
weather was good they were making really
good progress 10 to 12 miles a day which
was actually quite good in those
circumstances yeah yeah so August 6th
they get to the Weber River now when
they get there they found another note
from Hastings who said yeah um don't
follow us down Weber Canyon because it's
impassable however there is another
trail through the Salt Basin so I would
suggest that you take that instead so
they're finding little notes from this
dude like he's going up and going oh
this trail is not what I imagined at all
and he's trying to warn them you know in
in his defense he is trying to warn them
but it was his stupid idea that set them
out on this route to begin with so at
this point so they decide they camp out
near what is now hennifer I guess is how
you pronounce it Utah now James Reid who
was the initial like you know organizer
of the party him and two other guys
decide they're gonna go out on horses
and they're gonna try and find Hastings
cuz he's like you know a couple stops
ahead of them so they actually did end
up finding Hastings party on the south
shore of the Great Salt Lake and
Hastings came back with read like part
way back and he like tried to show them
where like the new route was he's like
well you go this way it'll probably be
about a week right now at this stage
another family the
Reeves family who had been with them but
had fallen behind they caught up with
the Donner Party as well so now there's
87 people in 23 wagons so then they
decide okay so they're gonna take a vote
about which way they should go like
should we just go like backtrack
canticle early the safer way or should
we go this new way and apparently the
majority said that they should try this
new trail rather than going all the way
back to Fort Bridger and like setting
out the safe trail from there so they
decide they're gonna go the new trail
much to their ultimate ultimate
detriment so August 11th the wagon train
starts out through the Wasatch Mountains
now this was like a very
that was like thick forest they had to
like cut trees out like to make the way
that wasn't a path at what a road they
had to like make one terrible so they
were making very very slow progress as
they were doing like maybe two miles a
day if they were lucky which yes it took
them six days to travel eight miles oh
man yeah die of starvation is just doing
that well yeah this is just the start of
their problems it gets like way worse so
at this stage they're like okay well
we're not gonna be able to get all the
dis is a lot of wagons this is 23 wagons
so like we're not gonna be able to get
all the [ __ ] wagons through here this
is like a huge ordeal so we might have
to leave some of them behind and at this
point everyone's starting to get a
little cranky as they would and they're
starting to like say you know what the
[ __ ] like Hastings is a stupid
[ __ ] like told us to come this
way and it was fine and also they
started getting a little pissed off at
James Reid because he was the guy that
was like yeah we should generally listen
to this book and go this way because he
was the one that had kind of made the
decision for the whole entire party and
for you people who are not Americans the
distances they're talking about and the
speeds that they're going to miles a day
having to cut down brush to get the
wagons through it you're talking about a
journey equivalent to going to the
[ __ ] moon this is something that's
going to take four
ever there's not a road there's no road
okay that's wilderness I would have
[ __ ] turned right around its will
earn out of turn right around it almost
seems like a I mean of all the horrible
things that happen to these poor people
like on this [ __ ] trail I feel like
there was a an aspect of the sunk cost
fallacy going on it's like once you get
so far they're like no we can't I give
it up now we have to keep we've come so
far we had to go through so much [ __ ] we
have to keep going forward don't get in
we don't want to like go back yeah
because it feels like you're defeated or
it feels like you're like going maybe
but I have died because of that effect
well many people died in this urn [ __ ]
around they probably should have and and
at one point it was like it was just too
late to do that which is sad but it's
like it was just like like I said it was
one of those things where it's just all
these like tiny little bad decisions and
it wasn't necessarily just that they
were stupid it was just that well
somebody who apparently knew more than
them was like telling was giving them
bad advice was what was happening and
they listened to it which in hindsight
we can say yeah they shouldn't have done
that but I wasn't there so it's like I
don't know how convincing that dude was
I don't know you know what I mean so
it's like yeah so August 25th so like I
said everyone's getting like really
really crabby at this point like
starting to get really pissed off at
James Reid starting to get pissed off at
the dude that read the book for leading
them on this [ __ ] arduous journey but
it didn't need to be August 25th another
guy in the group
dies Luke Halloran he died of a
consumption that was near Grantsville
Utah now at this stage the food and the
provisions and stuff like that are
starting to run low and everyone is
starting to get a little bit worried
they had been it had been 21 days since
they had stopped at the Weber River and
they had only gone 36 miles in those 21
days which that's not good
that's not far no I can walk that in a
day with a [ __ ] Rock
yeah that's bad I mean if you really had
to you could walk that yeah in a day
always do 12 not really a big problem I
mean I walked seven or eight miles in
one day just accidentally because I was
lost it depends on the train my feet
hurt but that was about it
thirty a day of now I probably couldn't
do it depending on how much I was
carrying and the terrain but you know 20
that's not as doable
yeah that's doable you know especially
on flat terrain and I think they're
basically flat they're just talking
about women now I guess they're not
aren't they
this is mountain it's mountains
wonderfully trying to get dam wagons
through that because they thought it
would be easy
[ __ ] dumbasses well they I mean they
didn't know like I said the guy said oh
this is an easier route it's shorter
yeah but but when you say to see what
you're seeing
okay maybe like you go nice go back yeah
let's go the way that everyone else is
yeah that's what I would do I mean
that's what I would have I like to think
that had I been in that big group when
they split off I'd have been like yeah
I'm going this way
I'm not going this hack in my bag as I'm
walking back yeah but yeah five days
later August 30th they search across the
Great Salt Lake desert now they believed
because Hastings had told them that this
journey across the desert would only
take two days yeah so what they failed
to realize though that the sand this is
still summer this is so good this wasn't
as worse it was gonna get like as bad as
it was gonna get cuz like winter weather
coming where is this again to Salt Lake
where this is in Utah Utah yeah
so the desert sand is very deep and like
wet so the wagons gonna cross it would
like sink like down into the sand which
slowed them down considerably
now they had only they were crossing the
desert on the third day their water
supply was almost gone and James Reed's
oxen were like we're out and they ran
away damn because they were smarter than
the people evidently wonder what
happened to them I'm sure they probably
wandered off and died but they were
probably just like yeah well I'm gonna
go he's got to be better than this where
everyone's like yes so they said the
oxen a lot of the oxen took off so they
finally it took them five days to get
across the desert they thought it would
only take two so check him five days now
four they actually got to the base of
Pilot peak on September 4th and rested
there for several days like the camped
out there now this the trek across the
desert which was 80 miles during that
trek they had lost 32 oxen damn James
Reid had had to abandon two of his
wagons and the Donner family and if the
Casa Berg family had lost one wagon each
they had to leave them in the sand
because they couldn't get them out the
oxen are like what the [ __ ] are these
people doing that's what I'm saying
the oxen were kind of smarter than the
people on this they're like you know
what you'll probably die over here but
anyway yeah this is not because like if
we stay here we're probably gonna get
eaten by the people so we're just gonna
go yeah I think I don't have been eating
suboxone at this point well they did end
up doing that yeah
but several of their oxen did run off
because they probably knew what was
coming
yeah like I said the oxen were poor very
smart so they get to the far side of the
desert and they take a stock of all
their food inventory and they found that
they had some left but it wasn't going
to be enough because they still had 600
miles to go and they're like yeah we
don't have enough for that
yeah and also around this was like early
September also they noticed that it
started to snow right later in the upper
parts of the mountains which you know
it's never a good time because like I
said up in the mountains up in that high
altitude you're gonna get start getting
snow they've kind of taken the easy way
very early in the year it's just gonna
get worse as to why they built that big
train
haha much easier than this yeah so they
get to the Humboldt River on September
26th which is my birthday actually so
what it up happening then they're like
okay so our supplies are running low so
two of the guys who were travelling with
the party William McCutcheon and Charles
Stanton they said okay well you guys go
ahead to Sutter's Fort California like
you just go by yourselves and bring
supplies back to the party so apparently
the okay so the two of them like took
off now from separate September 10th
from the 25th the party had been
following the trail into Nevada through
the Ruby mountains they had got the
Humboldt River on September 26 as I said
now here the new trail met up with
Hastings original path now this was an
extra $120 miles shorter however it was
actually 125 to 150 miles longer but
they didn't know that at the time
because like I said this was like
unmapped and untested so okay so the
Donner Party as it was then called they
get to the junction with the California
trail about seven miles west of
present-day Elko Nevada and spent the
next two weeks traveling along the
Humboldt River at this point because
food was scarce and they had been
together for a very long time under very
poor conditions everyone was starting to
get a little grouchy as you can imagine
and was starting to like fight with each
other and kind of get a you know get on
each other's nerves
October 5th there at iron Point two
wagons kind of like hit each other
became like kind of like tangled up at
some point like I guess one hit the
other one and they couldn't pull the
horses - yeah yeah or oxen yeah
so one of the Teamsters like the guys
that you know like drive the teams of
animals whose name was John Schneider he
starts whipping the remaining oxen to
like trying to get the wagons apart
James Reed the one time leader of the
group does not like that the guy is
whipping the oxen so he decides that
he's gonna stab us yes it was an animal
rights and leave them knocks on wall you
babe you promised and he stabbed him in
the stomach
yeah which killed him yeah now we're at
the [ __ ] either their wits with this
[ __ ] there were yeah there were over it
yeah let's say that they were over it
now
the party convenes and they're like okay
well what are we gonna do about it's
like he just murdered a dude he's like
bring it on what are you gonna do well
now like one of the guys and the same
said hang it hang the [ __ ] but
most of the other people the party were
like well we don't really they weren't
that far gone yet so they're like well
maybe we should just banish him which is
essentially the same as killing him
because you're sending him out on his
own in the wilderness like in the
untamed wilderness so that's what they
did
they sent like his family was still in
the party yeah you know what I mean but
they were like yeah you get the [ __ ] out
so they sent James Reid away him and
like one other guy so the party keeps
traveling along the Humboldt River and
at this point like the oxen that they
have left cuz like I said a bunch of
them had like run away because they were
smart the ones they had left were like
really worn out so they were trying to
walk instead of you know getting like
riding it was like getting the oxen to
like pull the wagons or whatever so just
to spare the animals and to keep them
from getting exhausted so these people
are like walking like next to the oxen
yeah and [ __ ] like that so two days
after John Schneider was killed another
guy got turned out of the group now
was an older guy a Belgian fella named
hard coupe now he apparently could not
keep up with everybody because he was
older and his feet were swollen from all
the walking so he started going around
to like the other wagons and like trying
to get them to like give him a ride and
stuff but nobody would Dan so one of the
guys like one of the patriarchs the
family's Lewis Katzenberg said like yeah
well you just stay here so they left the
old guy by a tree damn and then they did
they left them to die essentially
because they said well you can't keep up
so ye that's what they did it was known
at that point it was at that point yeah
October 12th weren't they ever found his
body I don't know bet you're not i
probably not like it you know the
wilderness is very very large some 80 I
would assume October 12th their
remaining oxen were attacked by Paiute
Indians who killed 21 of them with
poison tipped arrows to em just because
they were like hey told you have a
Minion's a [ __ ] plan yeah they didn't
like it October 16th four days later
they reached the Gateway to the Sierra
Nevada on the Truckee River red around
present-day Reno Nevada
almost all of their food was gone at
this point now three days later on
October 19th one of the dudes because
remember I said they sent the party out
to Fort cetera California that said hey
go get supplies and bring him back
Charles Stanton one of the guys he
actually did come back he came back and
he had seven mules and he had like a
whole bunch of beef he had some flour he
had two Indian guides and he said okay
well I have like there's a path through
the Sierra Nevada it's hard but you can
do it you know I mean like it's not
super bad so he came back with like good
news so everybody's like hurray
now what had happened the other guy that
they sent out with Stan William
McCutchen he had actually gotten sick
and he was still at the fork you
so he didn't die on the trail or
anything like that he was fine he was
just too sick to come back so the whole
wagon train they camp out for five days
50 miles from the summit of this
mountain because they said well we have
to go up the summit of this mountain
together than that the oxen like have to
rest because this is gonna be like a
hard push now the problem was that
because they waited so long and this was
another thing too they sent out a little
bit later than even like when they when
they first set out on this journey they
set out like probably a week or two
later than they should have which was
another thing that contributed to
because if you wait too long you know
you're gonna be in the worst terrain in
the worst part of the year you know what
I mean and people had done that so they
were just like hey don't leave later
than like May first because then you're
gonna be up in the Sierra Nevadas in the
middle of winter and you're just gonna
get buried in the snow and that's no fun
for anybody like I said so that was
another thing but so so they're waiting
and they're gonna go you know rest in
the Ox and they're like okay we're gonna
make this final push over the mountain
everything's gonna be fine now October
28th James read he gets to Sutter's Fort
in California he meets up with William
McCutchen the guy that they sent out
earlier he was sick and who had been
sleeping at the fort he had gotten
better so they said okay well we need to
get out like all our [ __ ] together
because like I said James Reed had been
thrown out for killing that guy so he's
like all right we're gonna like stock up
on supplies and we'll go back to because
their families were still back in the
wagon train they weren't just like
single dudes or anything so they had a
reason to go back like their wives and
children we're still back with the wagon
train so they're like okay well we're
gonna get we're gonna get stuff and
we're gonna go back now
wagon train continues to the base of the
summit Gorge Donner's wagon axle broke
and they ended up falling behind the
rest of the party 22 people this would
be the Donner family and some of their
hired dudes
stayed behind while the wagon was
repaired now unfortunately in something
that would come back to bite them in the
ass later on George Donner was trying to
cut timber for a new axle and the chisel
slipped and cut his hand open Oh
infection guys yes and it got infected
like later on well it got infected later
on so bad that he can but but for a time
he couldn't use it so he was essentially
one-armed right which is not good in
this situation because you need to like
cut trees and [ __ ] [ __ ] like that
so that emissions a cluster that's what
I mean
every it's like everything just like it
just built and built it seemed like God
hated these people and so if there was a
God he hated these people because
everything that could go wrong went
wrong and it's like just little [ __ ]
oh my wagon wheel broke I'm gonna fix it
all right yeah that and then he can't
use his arm right I mean and then like
it got infected that's terrible so the
party keeps going they get to a lake
which actually is now known as Donner's
lake it wasn't called that then and then
it starts to snow so Charles Stanton and
the two Indians who were traveling with
them you know who were their guides they
kind of tried to scout ahead to the
summit but they couldn't really go any
farther than that because the snow was
starting to fall so they pretty much
they they started going back there like
look man it's like already five feet of
snow this is not a good situation
now the pass through the Sierra
Mountains was very narrow it was only 12
miles from where they were camped
however the snowfall was so heavy and
they had so many wagons and this pass
was so narrow they couldn't get through
it so essentially they tried and then
they were like yeah [ __ ] that so then
they went back and they had to camp out
at the eastern end of the lake you know
where the ground was flat there was like
a bunch of trees and [ __ ] now where they
camped out there was actually one cabin
that had
somebody had built their like at some
other point I guess it was some other
settler so they're like okay well we'll
take that one over and then they had to
like cut down a bunch of trees and build
like some other shelters for people to
stand because they're like look we're
not going anywhere so we have to build
some shelters to stand for - wait this
storm out because just it was just feet
and feet of snow like dumping on them so
they built two more cabins which had the
house so these three cabins like one
that was abandoned and two that they
built was housing 59 people so you can
imagine how many people are crammed into
each cabin so and 59 people been I would
imagine if they're leaning heavily on
one another - mm-hmm they're not doing
anything to help the situation they're
trying to wait until somebody else does
it
how much trying to bet I've seen that
before I don't know it really does seem
like most of the people in this
situation from everything that I read
most of these people had done these
types of things before maybe not in this
exact terrain but a lot of them had like
you know traveled around and like been
settlers and other places and like built
ER and cabins and [ __ ] they weren't like
clueless but it does seem like a lot of
[ __ ] and like I said this winds we're
gonna do behind it's pretty [ __ ] hell
oh well they probably figured look he's
old which is sad but that's probably
what they thought I could have just put
him up in a damn [ __ ] you know I
don't know why they just ride away well
the thing is I think they were trying to
preserve the oxen and at that point I
think they thought that the oxen were
more valuable than it would be because
at least how much good and that big a
wagon how much could that [ __ ] have
weighed though I bet you that [ __ ]
didn't way hotter than 30 pounds you
could have put it in a dish it wasn't
like in 500 years and that that like an
oxen wouldn't even know the difference
maybe not yet that does seem like kind
of shitty
it seems kind of shitty like I said they
made some shitty decisions later on and
you could always rotate him yeah you
could like move it because there was a
lot I can't be in this one
today and tomorrow you being the other
wagga wagga that's right mm-hmm yeah so
there's 59 people staying in three
cabins and it just keeps snowing and
snowing so and they had to build like
some other shelters out of [ __ ] he
would have died later on though now I'm
thinking about it during the starvation
period but well yeah because and as you
will see almost all of the people that
died on this expedition were men most of
the women survived and a lot of the
children survived - mm-hmm but yeah so
they had to build other shelters - out
of just like anything they had like
[ __ ] quilts buffalo hides [ __ ]
tents [ __ ] like that so they're all just
kind of like hunkering down there like
okay well we're just gonna camp here
because obviously they couldn't go any
further there was only this one narrow
pass you know that was the only way out
and they couldn't navigate it because it
was too small and it was like covered
with [ __ ] snow so they actually made
two more attempts to get over the pass
at this point the snowfall was 20 feet
deep um and at this point they're like
yeah we're not going anywhere
so they started constructing more small
cabins next four months pretty much they
just hunkered down to this one area for
months and these little [ __ ] cabins
and like just try to like build little
shelters that have like whatever they
had like they built cabins they have
like little lean tools like whether they
eatin quilts and [ __ ] like that
oh you'll see No so at this stage James
Reid and William McCutcheon who like I
said had gotten to to California and
we're coming back like to meet up with
their families they were attempting a
rescue mission now two days after they
left California it started to rain and
as they started going up the mountains
the rain turned into snow so they got
about 12 miles from the summit and they
couldn't go any farther so they had to
basically take the food that
they had brought like all the [ __ ] that
they'd brought for their families and
whatnot they had to cash them like kind
of stow them in Bear Valley then they
had to go like backtrack back to
California and hoping that they could
like get more people to come with them
and get more supplies you know so they
could get back out and rescue their
families now the problem was that at
this stage the Mexican War had started
up so a lot of able-bodied men in the
area had gone to fight in that so there
weren't like a lot of you know just
stray dudes around that you could kind
of like send out on a rescue mission to
the [ __ ] snow-covered Sierra Nevada
mountains to save your wife and children
so they thought they're like okay well
when we left the party they still had
some cattle left so they probably have
enough meat to get through the winter
that was not the case
it seemed that a lot of the cattle had
already been had either died runoff or
been consumed November 29th the settlers
at Donner Lake killed the last of their
oxen for food the day after they did
that five more feet of snow fell onto
their camp and they're like okay well
we're not getting out of here at this
stage all of their animals pretty much
were gone like I said they'd either been
eaten or they had wandered off into the
snow and died they had killed all their
cattle and they had resorted to eating
pretty much any if they had any like
leather they would just boil it you know
they started eating twigs I wonder why
they did that I guess they didn't know
any better there's no nutrition in them
well the men started hunting but they
couldn't really find anything I guess
like this like I said this was one of
the worst winters on record like this
Tomiko leather yeah there's no nutrition
in leather I mean what they figured well
it was once like animal skins - maybe
there's some enough there's not but they
did - waste of time it's better than not
eating anything
cuz they're making that's what they're
thinking was because you're eating
[ __ ] clothing although it's probably
the clothing of the dead but there's
still no nutrition in it
well yeah but like I said they wouldn't
know that they were just like look
anything they could eat right would be
something better than nothing that's
that's what I'm thinking yeah
December 15th dude in the party named
Bayliss Williams died of malnutrition
and they figured okay at this point like
they didn't get to the point where
they're like hey we should eat that dude
yet however that dude dying of
malnutrition did kind of light a fire
under their asses so they got together a
party it was five men nine women and one
child and they made some kind of like
crude snowshoes and they said okay we're
gonna go out and we're gonna walk the
hundred miles to Sutter's Fort and we
will bring a rescue party back here this
rescue party was called the forlorn hope
mmm so hey so they [ __ ] alright so
they put on snowshoes and they set out
on foot in the snow for a hundred final
journey
they were like desperate at this stage I
mean this is pretty badass you have to
think it's like they they didn't have
any other choice really so they set out
with a little they had like some food
rations and stuff like that however they
were only out for six days and then
their food ran out for the next three
days they just starved you know and like
I said these are like you have to think
the Donner Party endured I believe it
was six blizzards on their [ __ ]
journey yeah like I said nature hates
you yeah so yeah so three days nobody
eats Charles Stanton who was on this
party he was not able to keep up with
the party and like told them to go ahead
now one problem to that I think a lot of
people don't I mean not only were they
starving and like the [ __ ]
conditions were horrible because you
have to think they had snowshoes but the
snow was so deep that every time you
took a step your foot would go all the
way down the snow need to bring it all
the way back up and you hadn't eaten
anything like shoes and [ __ ] so you
didn't have like any energy yeah so the
just the energy of like having to bring
your foot up like every single step you
took was just like really really
exhausting and another thing too was
that and this is something that isn't
address much is snow blindness and I
don't think that people back then knew
what snow blindness was it's basically
the ultraviolet rays like bouncing off
the snow damage your eyeballs and if
you're out in it long enough you will
actually go blind permanently yeah
fry your [ __ ] eyeballs yeah is
basically what it does um but in the
short term it really does like [ __ ] your
eyes up and you can't really see where
you're going I mean not to mention to
that it's like it's just white
everywhere and you can't really tell
what direction you're going in so
Charles Stanton falls behind the rest of
the group keeps on walking however a
couple days after that yet another
blizzard hits them and they couldn't
keep a fire lit they couldn't like keep
going
several of the party died including a
Mexican guy that have been with him
who's named Antonio nobody knew what his
last name was sadly Irish dude named
Patrick Dolan Franklin graves and a dude
named lemuel Murphy they all died and
the rest of the party ended up having to
eat them yep as you would so by the time
so they actually did end up having to
eat the people that had died by the time
they got to the western side of the
mountains On January 19th 1847 there
were only seven of them left only two of
the ten men survived
William Eddy and William Foster were the
only dudes that survived all five women
lived I don't know why I maybe because
when women have higher
contact we can we can start longer maybe
they were fed more yeah might be trying
to defend the women and children yeah
that might have been a factor also women
do have like higher fat content too so
it's like they might laugh longer in
that situation too but they didn't do as
much physical exertion the men were
doing most of the work the well-being
we're just not from anything I've read
it's like pretty much everybody was
doing the same [ __ ] it's walking well
yeah that's all they were doing was like
walking yeah no one was hunting no one
was doing anything like they was just
walking in snowshoes they were just
trying to get to California so they
could get supplies and get people to
come back and like get up a rescue party
like help everybody so of the eight
people who died on this particular
forlorn hope journey seven of them had
been cannibalized now they actually sent
out a bunch of they they did get to a
like an outpost where they could send
out messages and say hey look there's
like all these other people and they're
stranded like and they said where they
were it's like can we please get up like
a rescue party to go and help them so
they actually were successful in doing
that
February 5th the first relief party
which was seven men they left a ranch
called Johnson's ranch and then there
was a second party which was headed by
James Reed who would you know was the
first guy that organized the Donner
Party and they left two days later now
February 19th the first relief party
gets to the lake where the Donner Party
had been camping they get there and they
thought everyone was dead because
everything was just covered with snow
there was like there was just like
cabins and it was just like desolate and
they were like just creeped down there
like oh [ __ ] like everybody's dead and
then this one creepy woman like comes
out of the [ __ ] snow and she says to
them she said something to the effect of
like are you men from California or are
you from heaven that's what she said
dang yeah she was they said she looks
like a ghost like coming out of the [ __ ]
so at this point twelve of the party the
they'd come back to rescue we're dead 48
were left however many of them were very
very ill were barely alive or had gone
completely mental because of hunger
right now so the relief party had got to
them but they couldn't take all of them
at once I mean there was still 48 of
them so they couldn't like take them all
out at once and they couldn't bring that
much food back to them because the
relief party was small so the first part
relief party
they got actually 23 of the refugees and
you know were able to get them out of
there however while they were going back
to California
two of the peep two of the children in
that group passed away now while the
first relief party was going down the
mountain the second relief party was
coming up the mountain so finally James
Reed got to see his family members
because they had been they were some of
the refugees that were coming down with
the first relief party so he actually
got to see it had been like four or five
months since he had seeing them so he
was like reunited with his family at
that point which was kind of nice even
though that guy was kind of a douche so
March 1st the second relief party gets
to the lake and finds that so many
people hurt ed and so many people have
been eating each other yeah so they get
to alder Creek where a lot of the camps
were find that the donners had also
resorted to cannibalism
March 3rd James Reed left the camp with
17 of the immigrants just two days after
that though like he's trying to rescue
them and that there was guess what
another blizzard dam because nature
hates you
so by the time that Blizzard had passed
Isaac Donner a member of the Donner
family had died and most of the refugees
that he had picked up the 17 of them
couldn't really travel anymore because
they were too weak they were too hungry
James Reid and another guy named Hiram
they took three of the refugees with
them and they said okay well we'll go up
and we stored some food over here like
during our last like Trek so maybe we
can find that the rest of the rest of
them stayed behind this camp which ended
up being called the starved camp which
because everyone was starving you know
March 12th there was a third relief
group this was led by William Eddy and
William Foster who were the pretty much
the two men that survived from the first
foray they got to starve camp mrs.
graves and her son Franklin were dead by
this point their bodies and the body of
Isaac Donner who had died earlier had
been eaten hmm
the following day they get to the lake
camp both of their sons were dead March
14th they arrived at the altar Creek
camp to find George Donner was dying
from infection from that hand when he
was trying to fix the wagon wheel yep
that ended up killing him yeah his wife
knows what six months before it was a
couple of months before yeah okay like
it yeah 6:00 or two it wasn't yeah it
wasn't all think it was six months but
it was like a couple of months ago right
so George's wife Tamsin who was actually
a believed his second wife third wife or
something like that um she was actually
still in fairly good shape but he was
dying but she wouldn't leave him so she
basically they they have three daughters
together and she sent her daughters with
the rescue group she said no just take
them I'm I'm not leaving him she
wouldn't leave her husband
you know which is kind of nice but you
know didn't end up so well so the relief
party leaves with her daughters and a
couple more members of the party they
left behind ones that were too weak to
travel two of the rescuers Jean Baptiste
Trudeau and Nicholas Clarke they got
left behind to care for the Donner Party
but
soon they were just like I guess because
they were so sick and they were dying
they were just like [ __ ] that and then
they left and then like caught up with
the [ __ ] party that was leaving so a
fourth rescue party gets sent out in
late March but they got stranded and yet
another snowstorm for several days April
17th this relief party reached the camp
and found only Louis Casa Berg alive
among the mutilated remains of his
former companions damn he was eaten
among well he was the only one left like
a lot of people had died that there
wasn't like a lot of I don't know like
there was one documented murder okay
Jesus did murder that guy but it did
seem like most people were just dying
and people were eating them because they
were desperate it wasn't kind of like a
thing where hey let's kill people and it
seemed like these were good people who
just kind of like had to resort to that
because they didn't know what else to do
they were gonna die otherwise so it
wasn't like you know it wasn't an Alfred
packer situation where he's just like
I'm just gonna kill him to eat him but
just because right these people really
did not want to eat because there were
some you know there were some accounts
that when they actually did have to cut
up and eat the people they would like
they would go to separate fires so that
you wouldn't have to eat your own
relatives right right you know what I
mean and they would like immediately
like cut off the heads and stuff like
see so they weren't recognizable yeah
like they would join a deep person yes
they would do like [ __ ] like that and
they and they did seem to take great
pains even though they were starving to
be like hey that's not cool to like make
a mom eat their own daughter or you know
what I mean so they did seem to like
still hew to that even in these
desperate circumstances I think a little
bit of that went by the wayside like
later on as everyone was like starving
to death but they did really seem to try
to like adhere to some kind of like cuz
that's pretty [ __ ] up like having to
eat your own [ __ ] family members even
though at some stage or so so I've read
it got to a point where some of the
people that were dying we're basically
saying to their kids hey once I taco I
didn't eat me it's okay well it's like
that in tribal society yeah wish you
would understand I mean like you know if
your kid was gonna die if they didn't
eat you I mean any parent you would
think would say the same thing yeah I
mean there's a lot of tribal societies
you know they had ritualistic yeah
anabolism when somebody died it was a
gift back to the family of a good meal
you know which is a trip but there were
some but it's understandable tribes they
have situations there wasn't a lot of
meat you know something that was kind of
hard earned so yeah yeah I get it well
and if you watch there's a really good
um you know the the channel that ask a
mortician she did like about a half-hour
show about the Donner Party she went to
like the you know the the State Park and
everything where all the memorials are
and stuff and she kind of talked about
because you know she's a mortician so
she talks a lot about like funerary
practices and stuff so she does actually
talk about the distinctions between
different types of cannibalism and she
does go a little bit into you know
tribes that it's kind of like a
ritualistic or like a sacred type of
thing where it's not like offensive it's
just like you're you're absorbing their
power like into yourself or you're like
making them live forever because you're
eating them and there was like becoming
part of your body so so a warrior
cannibalism yeah there's yeah she made
that distinction you know very common in
Africa but I think I think it happened
also [ __ ] probably in Europe too over
the times you know you kill a
[ __ ] cuz he's a badass you might
as well eat him yeah you know well free
meat it's free me and maybe you can
absorb some of his badassery yeah that
was the thinking behind it well anybody
understand that it comes from poverty
though when you really get down to it
yeah that you don't have anything yeah
maybe you got a [ __ ] maximize
efficiency nothing goes to waste I mean
there is you can understand like why
there is um
sheral yeah you know disinclination
toward cannibalism for a reason but in
desperate circumstances or in certain
ceremonial certain circumstances it does
occur wouldn't surprise me that like in
ancient European battle probably around
Russia and Middle East you mean that
Middle East but Eastern Europe back in
the you know 1200 1114 hundreds of
Prabhas you know they didn't get much to
eat back in those days and some of those
battlefields had [ __ ] several hundred
dudes dying on both sides and after the
[ __ ] battle there's all these dead
bodies laying around you know are you
gonna let that go to waste when your
army hasn't been feeding you it wouldn't
surprise me even better I mean in
desperate situations you're kind of like
well it's terrible but meeteth me even
some of the even in the Napoleonic Wars
yeah I mean where they're Napoleon's
invading Russia those dudes were [ __ ]
desperate it would not surprise me that
if [ __ ] battlefield meat was was was
rendered yeah you know Dhamma why
wouldn't you that's why it's like it's
kind of a shame that I mean I don't know
if it's a shame but like the Donner
Party or just known for the cannibalism
but anybody that was in that situation
you would do the same thing you're
trying to stay alive you're trying to
keep your family love your children
alive
I mean obviously if people are just
dying of other [ __ ] you know why not eat
that right it's like you know what I
mean it just seems like there's no
supply chain there's no parable but it's
no other choice there's any other food
right practical concerns right and it
really does seem like I mean nobody got
charged with murder or anything like
that like I said the only person as far
as I know that murdered anybody was
James Reed who stats not like you could
just go up the street to the circle-k
right and get a hot pocket
those days those days weren't there
that's just not there it's a human hot
pocket yeah you've been flavoring right
but yeah it's a that's the thing it's
like so I don't really blame them
because really it seems like they had
exhaust
did all of their yes they made a couple
of dumb decisions but like I said it
wasn't entirely their fault because they
were given some really bad advice and it
really does seem like they ended up in
this situation and they didn't really
have any other choice
and they exhausted all of their other
options I mean they had already eaten
all their oxen they had eaten their
[ __ ] shoes and clothes and [ __ ]
roofs and that was a long terrible
journey
yeah and they you know they were [ __ ]
gonna go out west to paradise this is
like the worst winter ever and they got
stuck in it and they didn't know what
else to do and people were dying and
they didn't kill them that people just
died of starvation or of exposure or
whatever so it's like why not eat them
yeah you know I mean I was [ __ ] up but
it's like if you're in that situation
what else you gonna do like I said it's
like the [ __ ] Uruguayan rugby team
it's like the crash and the [ __ ] man
they were require throws over Argentina
I'm pretty sure there was a yeah but
yeah they crashed in the mountains and
they're like they didn't know if
anybody's coming to rescue them or not
it's like people were dead it's like
we're not situation all he had to do is
just go down the mountain there's a road
there but they didn't know they didn't
know that they weren't from there the
[ __ ] plane crashed in the funded
mountains for all they knew they were
just going out of the wilderness
yeah but so it ended up like with all
the rescue parties cuz like rescue
parties did go out there like to be fair
it took for rescue parties and two
months to rescue what was left of the
Donner Party now like I said I it's
weird because I learned about this in
school and I always kind of like took
away that they had all died but they
didn't two-thirds of the men in the
party died 2/3 of the women and children
lived so all in all 41 individuals dead
46 lived out of the original party five
had died before reaching the mountains
35 perished at the mountain camps or
trying to cross the mountains one died
just after getting to the valley even
those that survived had various problems
most of them had lost most of their toes
because of frostbite and whatnot
so because the story of the Donner Party
was so widespread like of course the
media had a [ __ ] field day because
cannibalism everybody wants to read
about so a lot of newspaper it does um
which you know that's understandable
everything was fear about cannibals and
I'm sure there was a lot of fake news
mixed in with it well probably that's
how they were back then and tain't even
today well I'm sure they probably like
you know ramped it up like oh um they've
murdered each other and killed each
other that's not mother is eating their
babies which that's not exactly what
happened it's like yes there was at
least one murder I'm not saying that
there weren't more than that but I do
feel like most of this was just like the
circumstances and it was just like
horrible circumstances anybody would
have done and I think anybody would have
done the same thing if they wanted to
stay alive and particularly if they had
a family that they were trying to keep
alive also they were pushed to the
[ __ ] limits yeah I mean this is like
every like I said every horrible thing
that could happen to these people happen
to them it's like not only were they
[ __ ] lost and they were in these
horrible like but six blizzards you guys
six blizzards they ran out of food they
didn't have the right [ __ ] equipment
it's just like they didn't they were
stuck by this [ __ ] lake they couldn't
get this through this [ __ ] pass they
didn't know where they were going and
it's just like you know what are you
gonna do you can't go to the [ __ ]
7-eleven and get a cup of coffee or
nothing like that it's just there's
nothing there's nothing else you can do
is that it what else is well fairly okay
so well all I was gonna say was that
after after this story came out about
the Donner Party um like emigration to
California understandably decreased
decreased yeah immensely cuz it was like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] I do I don't we don't we
don't want to go there that bad so the
Hastings cutoff which was what had
caused all of the heartache from the
beginning people like largely forgot
about it however in 1848 only a couple
of years after the tragedy somebody
discovered gold that's
Mill in Coloma California and suddenly
the gold rush was on and everybody
started going out there again and forgot
all about that [ __ ] well they didn't
forget about it but it's just kind of
like [ __ ] that gold yeah and the gold
rush was the beginning of the Wild West
as you know it from the [ __ ]
Hollywood viewpoint the a point of view
that's when all that shit's [ __ ]
happened yeah yeah and there wasn't much
gold that was it was a it was a mean
there was gold but not that much it
seemed like there was enough for like
individual prospectors to go there and
like find enough to live on but I didn't
really see their there didn't really
seem to be like that many people like
going out there becoming like [ __ ]
fabulously wealthy out of the [ __ ]
they're you would go out there and you
get like a living a living wage later on
there were some people that said that
the whole there's gold and then their
hills effort was a government-backed
[ __ ] SIOP to get people to go run
west to help colonize the west a lot of
it had to do with you know me [ __ ]
the the mexican-american war - to fill
that [ __ ] area well as I may not been
the whole reason that the you know that
the emigrants got a guide to Oregon in
California yeah the whole reason that
Hastings got popped got famous and that
book got famous I mean he was like
working with a company in California
that was trying to get people out there
to sell land so it might have been like
some big private corporation yeah that
was trying to get more people to move
there so they could sell plots of land
which was demonstrably the situation in
this case I mean that's why he was
trying to get and that's why he promoted
in his book hey I've got this short cut
that he had never even [ __ ] done and
then when he he tried to do it the same
time that the Donner Party was doing it
he was like oh yeah this is not working
out he did live but he didn't take his
shortcut you know what I mean like he
took part of the shortcut and he's like
oh yeah this isn't working and he told
them but then like he just like won
another way yeah that's kind of
like you know a lot of people will
[ __ ] lay everything at the feet of
the [ __ ] American government during
this time the American government's
weakest [ __ ] it really didn't have much
power outside the [ __ ] eastern
seaboard I mean you hear nowadays all
these stories about well you know
Americans giving out cooking smallpox
blankets really the first time that was
ever mentioned in history was an idea
that a British officer had of maybe
doing against enemy Indians during the
[ __ ] French and Indian Wars over a
[ __ ] bunch of fur trading and there's
no evidence that that ever happened it
was just that an officer said may maybe
smallpox might help us but there didn't
seem to be any actual British attempt at
waging like a smallpox war the [ __ ] was
she was so vague back dad
yeah I mean there isn't any evidence for
anything a lot of this [ __ ] is just
[ __ ] well the thing about it is it's
hard to tell because I don't think
anyone back then would have had the
presence of mind to realize that Native
Americans did not have the same immunity
to Europeans specific disease that's
later so yeah I'm not saying that they
didn't give them blankets that were
infested with diseases but I don't know
if they did it on purpose right
it just kind of like happened because
they didn't know it I remember reading
that there's no evidence of that not
from those days I mean I would be
surprised if anybody back then had
presidents even think about that right I
don't think there was any kind of
smallpox blanket you know I mean [ __ ]
I mean it wouldn't shock me because even
in the Middle Ages they knew enough
about quote unquote we would use
chemical warfare you know one pp would
throw like plague bodies like over and
Oshea because they knew that they would
like right you know that it would in
fact the people inside so they did have
the presence of mind to do that so it
maybe is not that much outside of the
realm of what's out
the ruble the possibility though is the
American government doing it I don't
think they had the power or that [ __ ]
yeah if anybody would run a small-scale
if anybody were to do anything like that
it would be somebody like the railroad
or a corporation and back in those days
yeah that wouldn't shock me
corporations back in those days were
basically [ __ ] their own
nation-states they had nothing to do
with any other countries and matter of
fact a lot of them [ __ ] we're
operating here in the United States
outside the boundaries of the United
States yeah outside of the boundaries of
law which but still even they'd really
didn't have their [ __ ] together
they weren't [ __ ] smart to me it
would it seems more probable that they
would do somebody like that right there
maybe somebody in a corporation
somewhere might think of some would
think of that yeah that sounds plausible
but there's no evidence the thing is
there's not I'm just saying it sounds
more plausible to me than some weird
like blood in a government like
government the government the US
government during this area was during
this era was weak well organized like I
said out in the West which was they not
no ability to project power they didn't
really have any jurisdiction in that
area during this time here and it was
very sketchy si8 I'm telling you guys
man see Jeremiah Johnson John Milius
[ __ ] Jeremiah is out there trying to
survive and the American army comes to
ask him for help you know man and you
see how [ __ ] up you know the American
government was not a professional outfit
in there in this area era everything was
very ragged his [ __ ] ragtag [ __ ]
and they didn't know what the [ __ ] they
were doing everything was done just kind
of like by the people that were local
and there's not a lot of records it's
Mad Max times well and as I said like
looking looking more into this Donner
Party story you can really see how I
mean so much of the [ __ ] that happened
to them was because
no one had ever taken this particular
route before they didn't have any way of
knowing that this person that had
written this supposedly authoritative
book didn't know what he was talking
about so they didn't have any reason not
to take his word for it that oh he found
this better route out to California why
shouldn't we take that and it's sad
because that ended up killing half of
their party in a really horrific way
because they didn't and they didn't know
anybody these were not like dummies they
weren't like like I said these were
settlers they had done this [ __ ] before
they knew yeah you know the conditions
they were gonna be facing they had like
planned for four months on the road you
know in the wagon train they had stocked
up for that [ __ ] but it's like but it's
funny because most books about America
and the American continent were written
by people who didn't know that I was
talking about it wasn't really until the
internet age you were really kind of
able to check [ __ ] I haven't like as
much as as much as Hastings in this
situation like sucked at least I will
give him enough credit that even though
it even though the Donner Party had
already set out like following his
advice and that ended up very badly but
at least he did say hey maybe I should
go check out this route that I have like
given all these people like in my book
and he did actually do it for a little
while and he did try to warn them like
he did go one way and he's like yeah
this is not such a good idea and [ __ ]
like that but then he kind of pieced out
yeah so you know I mean nobody was wrong
yeah and it's like maybe he was
embarrassed he got at that point he's
like oh man this is like even worse than
I'm at he was looking at a map made by
somebody else that he's right yeah
that's really what he did yeah yeah
that's exactly what he did because he
didn't he didn't go on the route until
after the book had come out because he
left on the route the same day that the
Donner Party did yeah and the book had
already been out for a year or two by
that point as far as I can there's no
way that Matt
could have been a topographical map
showing it clearly it was not showing
where all the mountains were where all
the [ __ ] was it was just a general shape
on a piece of paper and he's gone he
look at a map and thought oh well
there's no mountains here in this like
area it's like drawn by the guy that
keeps like all drawn yeah there's no he
didn't draw anything here so it must
just be like [ __ ] just cake walking
through that cheese trip and I walked
over [ __ ] like that up in Korea [ __ ]
nobody want like I said [ __ ] the poor
[ __ ] downer party man it's like you
you think they're just like walking
through the desert [ __ ] wasn't it they
were climbing mountains yeah and they
had eaten nothing yeah they're climbing
mountains in like 20 feet of snow yeah
that'd be rough and they had wagons yeah
they had children hmm that they were
trying to like [ __ ] keep from dying
it's not a good situation yeah yeah so
what's up I mean like what's is that is
that can we wrap this up what's the end
of this story yeah well these people
well half of them died okay and went
into legend and now everybody remembers
the Donner Party as those people that
ended up having to eat each other
yeah even show up on the [ __ ] the
shining movie by Kubrick they eat each
other yeah some of them did they did I
forgot that like half of them actually
did survive because they sent rescue
parties in there like at least probably
[ __ ] that was worse than that where none
of them survived and we'll never hear
about it
the real because we don't even know
we're there cuz yeah the reason why we
know about the stories because a lot of
people survived yeah tells me that there
was a lot of were a lot worse [ __ ] to
happen out there and like I said this
this particular case and I think that's
one of the reasons that this is kind of
gone and gone down and like American
history is like a very famous story is
because it was very well documented it's
like the people that survived like wrote
extensive accounts of like what happened
so we know pretty much what happened at
every point right along the journey
because a lot of people did live yeah
that tells me that there were
parties of four and five people were a
lot worse [ __ ] happened and nobody knows
what happened there was no documentation
well like I said look at that for Packer
case were like this [ __ ] goes
off in the woods with five of their
dudes and yeah it's the head with a
hatchet and eat them I'm sure that
probably happened a lot back in the old
days cuz there's not like much you can
do about it just one guy walking alone
you know I mean for several months what
can eaten things as he goes he ends up
dying anyway
imagine that [ __ ] body never found
I just force every single time I think
of like the Alfred Packer story I just
think of like Yosemite Sam like walking
through like a cartoon desert and then
like he just like it's a nude pepper I
don't know why I think of that but yeah
I gotta go get the cat you get yeah
you're gonna get the print please go
find the kitty she like wandered off
both of the kids the Kitty's wandered
off somewhere yeah alright so I think
that will do it for episode 100 93 I
told the story hope you guys have
enjoyed this frontier cannibalism tale
yeah for pattern the Donner Party this
was a fun show actually yeah we'll see
you guys next week
regular people that listen to us all the
time [ __ ] like share subscribe and
you will hear from us on flashbacks we
do a flashback every [ __ ] day
sidetrack a sidetrack flashback I'm on
acid [ __ ] jar you I'm [ __ ] yes and
I wish I had some but now we do a
[ __ ] sidetrack everyday we do so many
shows now yeah the sidetracks are fun
everybody seems to be enjoying them we
do the sidetrack show we do the matinee
show which is like new movie reviews we
do old movie reviews I do that I do the
scary stories on Thursdays yep man we do
so many shows I can do a lot of shows
now yeah but there's rap the [ __ ] we
love you guys that's what that's why we
do this [ __ ] so hopefully you guys have
enjoyed episode 193 about frontier
cannibalism
tune in next time and remember if you
like the show as he said like share
subscribe if you'd like to financially
support you and get her
try'n page patreon.com/lenguin our blog
13 o'clock podcast up WordPress comm and
there's a button in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation we are also going to
do a YouTube membership which will
probably have the same perks as the
patreon thing you can get like early
access to videos we're good not so we
will get around to doing that I don't
know how long it's going to take for
YouTube to approve all the perks because
they have to do that but we're working
on that at the moment so until next time
bye
[Music]
you
[Music]